seconds did you ever think you would
make it I feel I'm so I take Sweet
Victory I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giving values
contagious world are entrepreneurs we G
no value to haters how run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
[Music]
one say what man say what say what all
right home team episode 362 holy moly we
got a lot of stories I feel like it's
been a minute but it's not been because
I think we did a podcast last Friday but
A lot's going on the the great Joe Rogan
got a quar of a billion dollar contract
renews with Spotify for I have some
thoughts on that congrats to both of
them we'll talk about that Tucker
Carlson spotted in Moscow what's he
doing there no one knows drinking a meal
is he playing a game is he there to
watch a show is he there just kind of go
on family vacation like you know you
know Bernie thander style is it like a
25 year anniversary to like re what do
you what is it when you're married and
you want to do it again you're like
there's a word for it Tom what's the
word reor not re celebrate there's like
you um you recommit your vows you
recommit your vow maybe he's
recommitting his vows but CNN lost their
minds they hate they're deeply concerned
be a caviar tasting maybe it is a valid
concern and we'll address that that's
their guy dare he aside from that 50
Cent blasts mayor Adams for wanting the
tournament to a quarter by giving
$53 million of prepaid credit cards to
migrant families and mayor Adams
responds with a request to says I hope
50 calls me and if you like would have
to say maybe even says something in in
his next song like he's saying can put
me next song we'll talk about that New
York City wants to give $53 million of
prepaid credit cards to migrant families
I'm a migrant I'll take I'll take some
right there Elon Musk uh got some issues
with Tesla they didn't approve his $55
billion pay package was struck down he
was told to go to rehab anyways we got a
bunch of stuff there we'll talk about
the stock how it's doing luxury home
values to decline across the globe
not across the country not across
California or the states the globe right
it's going to decline and and Tom's got
some numbers for Austin Nikki Haley
makes a surprise appearance at the SNL
and it was so good that she's about to
drop out of South Carolina that's how
good it was but it is what it is acting
and she said new States can't succeed
because people are worried about Texas
leaving and because Texas they're
forcing Texas to do some stuff with the
border and what if Texas wants to leave
and you know become its own Republic
we'll see what's going to happen there
polls with Trump this is a bad part Joe
if you're watching Joe Biden skip this
part on the podcast it's not I don't
even think he watches anything by the
way do you guys know he was asked for
the second year in a row to do the
traditional Super Bowl three-minute
interview you know he turned it down for
the second year in a row turn down the
traditional three you know every year
the president gets like the three minute
interview you know turn it down they
can't have they can't have him in that's
right by another hot mic Joy Reed had a
hot mic moment had to go on The View and
defend herself as the Christian non-war
person that doesn't like Abbott and
blamed it on Abbott this whole thing
with the hot mic was Abbott's fault you
know that right Abbott said say another
effing wart that was all Abid texting
saying you better say or El he forced
her that's what's going on there a lot
of drama going on we don't know again
this is pure speculation allegedly folks
these are Insurance words that we have
to use Baby Boomers are approaching Peak
burden on the economy Adam's deeply
concerned we'll talk about that fed
expects to make three rate Cuts this
year you know that Scar the crap out of
the market and a market tanked because
they wanted more rate Cuts not three
they wanted four they wanted to do what
LeBron said not two not three not four
not five not have you seen this when
he's going to Miami we going to win of
course Vermont is debating Vermont is
debating a millionaire tax
Massachusetts added 1 billion Jerry
scared what happened Ben and Jerry are
the billionaires oh then Vermont yes
Massachusetts added $1 billion to his
budget and paid for school lunches with
a similar tax that loses custody for
refusing to trans son how dare he what a
how dare he he's you're not letting your
kid choose his truth that's ridiculous
who cares if he's only 11 years old he
can think for himself six years old yeah
this kid was how old I think he was uh
he wa how about this he was way too
young and the mother by the way if you
guys watched 60 Minutes this weekend
excuse me 60 Minutes showed uh uh China
a video I'm going to show you guys this
is a crazy video I don't know 100% the
video that that in in China is going
viral on Tik Tok showing Chinese people
how to cross the border to the US St
through the through Mexico through
Mexico TK Tock win I'll show you this
video we'll have some fun with that in
China don't they have one of those
things that Trump was talking
about don't they have the Great Wall
China right well they definitely know
how to go over a w they're they pros at
it but border deal uh to cut illegal
immigration calling the border bul
border border deal but wait till you see
the money by when we break down the
money you're going to say this is not
the Border deal this is called the
Ukraine deal when you see the data
former uh Tesla director Larry Ellison
invited musk to Hawaii to dry out from
you know drugs apparently reports this
is Insider obviously Insider doesn't
like uh uh anything musk does and
there's a few other things here American
Hustle D maybe we'll get into that and
then uh we'll address a couple other
videos but before we get into it I I
want to give you guys a couple things to
be thinking about we had a meeting uh
early this year Monday January 3rd and I
said I want the merge future looks
bright to be in 1 million people's hand
this year okay I want a million people
wearing future looks bright hats my
concern isn't about the the the margins
or any of that stuff I want to fight off
all the negativity that's going on in
America by having a million people in
the streets the other day I was at
Universal Studios we had a great time
this weekend we went there hanging out
with trans people at the uh what do you
call it the U the uh uh
Mig when I'm saying I'm not joking with
you there was 50 trans LGBT dancing
talking to all the kids that were with
us hi half naked not talking to us they
weren't talking to us they were
literally and they were on on still
bending down talking to the park
coordinator there and I went up to this
weekend not Disney Universal Universal
and Tom you expect that at Disney
Universal I mean they're kind of
connected and then Tom goes up to one of
the guys that worked there and as I'm
walking white P say do you like the is
it a good life Tom was intered he go he
goes excuse me is this part of you guys
and then I walked away to the bathroom
Tom was checking him like how is this
cool but Dylan was talking D's like what
is wrong with these guys dad to do it
here 10-year-old kid was upset about it
anyways but I'm wearing a future looks
bright shirt the per the pur purple and
gold the one that was a limited one that
we did last week and I'm wearing a
purple and gold uh uh what do you call
it these hat right I'm wearing these I
think we have like 30 of these left in
honor of Kobe in honor of Kobe yes and
I'm wearing these and everyone's you
know future looks bright future looks
bright future looks bright conversations
right that are being started why is that
because people don't believe the future
looks bright today scares the crap out
of them when they see somebody say
future looks bright so this is what
we're doing today for anybody that
purchases any purchase you make today on
the store with a minimum of hat you have
to buy a hat obviously if you do an
order over 70 bucks shipping is on us
but anything you order with the hat that
says future looks bright we have a lot
of different colors the blacks the
military the white the red you pick and
choose you can even do these but any
orders you make today we're going to do
a raffle okay and on the Thursday
podcast we're going to announce two
winners that are going to get a ticket
to go to the Vault conference it's a
$750 ticket to go to the Vault
conference on the house because we want
you to spend 3 days with us in Palm
Beach at the Vault Convention Center
will be at the Palm Beach Convention
Center to make 2025 the beginning of the
greatest years of your life and when
you're around the value team and
audience they're just like you if you
follow this content you're like I follow
this content for this reason imagine
being in a room with 10,000 other people
that believe the future looks bright so
again R put a link below for anybody
goes and place the order by the way I
even think we have a a campaign going
right now that if you buy a hat you get
a second one for free uh and again if
you order $70 plus we're sending uh the
shipping and handling will be on the
house again a million people I want
wearing this worldwide confusing the
hell out of everybody that thinks the
future looks bleak I want it to be
future looks bright to start a
conversation because that's what this
brand represents by tment that the
future looks bright There's the link
right there for you buy one get one free
n of those hats and uh once again on
Thursday we'll announce two winners
going to the Vault with us love it to
spend three days with us having said
that let's get right into it okay I'm
going to do a story first Rob let's go
into the Joe Rogan uh story here so Joe
Rogan oh let's do Tucker Carlson since
that's the first one they want to
do Tucker Carlson being spotted in
Moscow Sparks frenzied speculation this
is Newsweek okay dramatic so former Fox
News host Tucker Carlson recent
president in Moscow where he was seen
attending the bull show theater on
February 1st has ignited speculation
about the purpose of his visit
particularly whether he games to
interview Russian Vladimir Putin during
his trip Republican representative Mar
margorie Taylor green Express excitement
about the prospect of Tua Carlson
interview with put in emphasizing the
importance of individuals like Carlson
and upholding a free press Democrats and
their propagandas in the the media are
spamming uh uh sping spasming at the
prospect of tuer Carlson interviewing
putting against this is a Newsweek story
we have a free press in this country and
it's people like Tucker Carlson who we
depend on to speak the truth in response
to these speculations Kremlin press
secretary Dimitri pesov referred to
Carlson's prior interview attempt with
put and stated we'll have to wait and
see whether such an interview
materializes okay so before I give my
thoughts on this Vinnie what are your
thoughts about this year I I I a I think
what he's doing is amazing I think uh in
the in the same sense of trump when
Trump was like for years when he was
like what is wrong with trying to
communicate with these people how are
you going to ignore an enemy why not sit
down talk talk to them find out what's
on their mind I think tucking Tucker
going there is is amazing to have a
conversation to see where he's at but
notice how the left is losing their mind
bad because they can't make him look
like he's a human being cuz everything
from the Putin price likee to the Putin
War everything has to be negative
negative negative don't talk because
guess what if you make him into a normal
civil person then it's harder to call
him an enemy on the news and and try to
start a war with them that's what it is
Tom what are your thoughts on this well
I think Tucker is trying to be a part of
the media we've had things where you
know a while back when I was a young guy
um I saw Barbara Walters interview Fidel
Castro weird and that was back when hey
it's a free press going to a foreign
country trying to interview a a
controversial World dictator to see what
he had to say is there a humanness under
that is there an opening there is there
something is that the one look at that
look how young look yeah this Barbara
Walters went and interviewed Fidel
Castro so why is it so freaking crazy
and that the Press is losing its mind
that Tucker Carlson wants to follow in
the footsteps of and by Barbara Walters
you know when you you read about her bio
she was a journalist from the Walter
kronite era she ended her life a little
bit now what we would call maybe a
little woke but she was a journalist so
why is it so crazy that that Tucker
Carlson goes to interview Vladimir Putin
to see what he's going to say and to see
if there's something there it doesn't
mean that he's being buddies with him
and taking him quail hunting that Tucker
likes to do in North Carolina it means
he's over there just to to talk to him
why is that so bad Adam
look um I think people want to see this
interview we had this conversation of
you know who's on your top five top 10
list of people you'd love to speak to
Putin is on that list um I don't
understand the obsession uh especially
on the far right Fringe that are pro
Putin people there's definitely talk of
that I don't think Tucker is pro Putin I
just don't think he is pro the war in
Ukraine the most ironic thing to me
though is this we're talking about this
Free Press
conversation uh when there's no free
press in Russia Russia is ranked 148th
out of 180 countries according to the
reporters Without Borders press Freedom
index the beautiful thing about America
is we have the First Amendment freedom
of the press freedom of expression
freedom of religion freedom to gather
everything we understand about that so
it's just interesting that the the
Bedrock of uh freedom of press America
uh Tucker Carlson arguably the biggest
reporter in the world right now is going
to speak to the dictator known as
Vladimir Putin
potentially and by the way CNN showed uh
uh they're like yeah and he is in
Kremlin where he's getting a free
battery charge without having to worry
about the Wi-Fi with being spied on and
you know obviously the news is saying
this and the CNN is making fun of the
fact that you trust the Wi-Fi in Russia
I don't know if I trust the Wi-Fi in
Russia I don't know if I'm you know when
you go to places like this you have to
know you don't necessarily know what
they're going to be doing to get access
to you you have to assume 100%
especially if your name is Tucker
Carlson that they're probably you have
to use a fresh laptop you have to go
with a fresh computer that's nothing
else is in there if that makes any sense
you have to be prepared you have to
think like a you know a person that
would be involved in some kind of secret
intelligence to see how they would be
thinking you have to and I'm sure he him
being who he is and his camps filled
with some sharp guys that you know we've
spoken to couple of them I'm sure
they're thinking that way but at the
same time competition is always
intimidated by a guy that's willing to
get on a plane and fly to Russia to go
interview somebody that everybody else
is so afraid of interviewing or you you
don't want to talk to because it's
opposing ideas look for
me I have my business plan here this is
very sacred this is only mine and nobody
gets to read this this is only for me
and it fires me up when I write my
business plan like this and I laminate
it it starts off with a letter to myself
and I got a list of guys that I'd like
to do certain things with you know who's
on my list of people I want to talk to
this year mudo Maduro is not a
right-wing guy I want to talk to Maduro
I want to talk to certain people who are
hardcore socialists I have certain
people on here that I like to talk to a
lot of people would say you would talk
to him you would talk to her yes I'm
curious okay we just did a podcast with
Bill Mah I enjoy talking to him I wish
it want a different direction but I
enjoy talking to the guy because it's to
see why is this person why does this
person think the way he does I'm excited
to see what he does in the interview and
odds wise do you guys have any odds on
what you think whether the interview's
taking place or not based on how the
media from Russia answer what do you
think the percentage is that's actually
he's there to interview Putin what is
the percentage I think 90% I think 90%
what do you say yeah I'm above 85% we'll
do like pric is right I'll go 85% Bob I
think it's uh highly likely that's why
he is there so yeah where you at% yeah
okay Rob you think it's going to be
happening I'm 5050 it's either Putin or
Snowden it's either Putin or Snowden
yeah snowden's hiding out in Russia um
but either interview would be fantastic
watch how about this when when's the
last time did an interview with free
Megan Kelly a while ago yeah Megan Kelly
what year was that oh uh six years ago 5
years ago so it's not when she first
went to NBC is when it got done so
whatever that time tried P so Tucker
tried to have an interview with P before
but we were we wouldn't let him or
something and they were America was
spying on him right according to Tucker
the NSA hacked his signal messages after
he was planning a trip to Russia to
interview Putin so the NSA started
spying on Tucker when they found out he
was going to go I believe it
that's this was when he worked for Fox
News he mentioned this when he did the
interview with the nek boys after he got
fired I fully believe this so ask you a
question if I was doing that going over
there I would start on my signal account
did you get the coke from Hunter I'd be
populating my signal account with all
these intentional messages what admits
the NSA hacked into the signal
messages by the way that means even
signal can get hacked into 1,00% of
course what but my question to you is
why why do you think I mean besides the
obvious why do you think the left is so
anti do not go speak with this guy why
why do they hate and they're trying to
stop him from going over there why do
they hate him speaking to Putin why why
doesn't CNN MSNBC mainstream media Biden
everybody does not want him to talk they
narrative well well no think about it
from this standpoint think about it from
this standpoint uh Obama went and hung
out with uh uh was it cha who was who
was he with in Cuba was it Chavez that
he went to a baseball game with I
thought he went to with Fel Castro's
brother his brother so he
went tr's Uncle go ahead yes so he went
to a baseball game with him and the
right said you know what kind of a
situation is this why would you go have
a conversation with him and what is is
this all about and D yeah the difference
is one is having a conversation the
other one is going to a game and being
entertained by game now if you ask me I
don't have any problem with him doing
this but if he also does it with the
other side I don't have any problem
doing that yeah like for me I like the
fact that Trump met with Putin I like
the fact that Trump met with G I like
the fact that Trump met with Kim I like
the fact that Trump meant with anybody
and everybody I like the fact that a
president's willing to sit down with any
of these guys to keep them close and
talk to them I like diplomacy I like
sitting there so you know who I am face
to face you see me kneecap to knap to
walk away saying okay at least this
guy's a deal guy that I can sit down and
have a conversation with I don't mind
any of that stuff taking place anyways
let's go to the next story before we get
into the next story of Rogan and a
little bit of insight on questions maybe
with Bill Mah because I don't know if
you seen the podcast or not at this
point I don't know if you've seen the
comments I think it's the most commented
podcast he's done 15,000 comments 14,000
comments I was being told this morning
let's first go to our sponsor go for br
so look I've been in the financial
industry since 9/11 the day before 911
and I've owned stocks bonds mutual funds
real estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
years is gold I love having a percentage
of my network in Gold that I have access
to in case of many different things
that's why we chose to work with our new
sponsor American Harford gold if you
have retirement funds that you cannot
afford to lose American Harford gold
will ship physical gold or silver
directly to your door also if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Harford gold a precious metal dealer you
can trust they have the finest products
amazing customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on the link in the
description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 okay all right so uh let's go to
Rogan Joe Rogan puts a video on his
Instagram account talking about Spotify
and he says he is renewing his deal good
stories come out Joe Rogan gets new
Spotify deal worth up to
million Spotify has reached a new deal
with star podcaster Joe Rogan that will
allow his hit show to be distributed
Brad Rogan's fresh deal estimated to be
worth a court of a billion dollars over
its multi-year term according to people
familiar with the matter involves an
upfront minimum guarantee plus a revenue
sharing agreement based on ad sales
under the new licensing agreement
Spotify will sell ads for and distribute
The Joe Rogan Experience across several
platforms including a video format on
YouTube which is kind of interesting and
I like that by the way because you would
want to grow the YouTube audience as
well I don't think the YouTube side was
maximized for Rogan and I'm glad they're
doing it this way so whether it was
Rogan's Camp negotiating that or
spotify's Camp doing that good for them
and the company said the Friday under
his previous deal the show was exclusive
to Spotify the New Deal is emblematic of
Shifting economics and podcasting which
has matured in both audience reach and
advertising spending since Rogan's last
deal Spotify is working to revise the
terms of its deals with top talent so
that shows are distributed on several
platforms uh to maximize Their audience
and AD sales rather than requiring
exclusivity Tom well this is great for
Joe Rogan it's great for people that
want to hear Joe Rogan in more places
because it's not exclusive now it's
Broad and this is this is basically um
Spotify acting like a capitalist Pat Uh
spotify's loss has been reduced to70
million EUR last year the loss of 70
million years you know $70 million is
not a lot of money um not not when
you're uh almost $4 billion of Revenue
Spotify is and a year ago they lost $270
million so Spotify has been trimming
things that don't work and renegotiating
and renewing in different ways things
that do work there's a big ad Rogan's
got a lot of upside on this on the ad
side the ad sharing he gets a lot of
Leverage up so rather than just paying
him straight straight straight they say
hey let's go broad let's not be
exclusive and we'll give you more of the
ad sales side so it's it's doing well
and Spotify had about a 7 % growth here
uh which is significant growing 177%
after we're all back from Co they about
a 17% Revenue growth on subscription
Revenue so Spotify is acting like a
capitalist company and this is them
betting on one of their hits and one of
their jewels to keep him at Spotify
broaden it out make more ad dollars and
grow the company and reduce the loss
this is this is good past five days look
at the stock is up
15.4% the market loves what they're
doing by the way if you go last last 5
days up 15.73% can you go to their
market cap right now see what their
market cap is uh what do you see Spotify
it should be right there bottom bottom
bottom right there $48 billion 48.2 48.2
billion so if they're up 15% if you do
divided by 85 what number do you come up
with Rob I know you can do it in your
head please so uh uh
uh okay so
48 uh uh it was for so they made they
made roughly $8 billion this week holy
crap they made roughly 6 to8 billion
hours this week closer to 8 billion this
week okay after announcing this that's
amazing for a quarter of a billion
dollars yeah and and you because you
know Joe very well like and it couldn't
happen to a a cooler they call The Joe
Rogan Experience because it's an
experience he's not only a comedian he's
teaching you you're learning this you're
finding out about history and he's not
afraid to talk to anybody he'll have
anybody on there and then when they time
for Trump yeah well we'll talk about
that later but and and yeah dude I mean
we still got our bet going right our bet
is still happening but what a what a
what a necessary voice and just like you
know you sing it with Elon the when
you're that awesome and you're that
popular and you're not scared of
everything and you're letting people
hear the truth they got to come after
you and I love the fact that uh him and
Spotify the CEO kind of were like okay
and they just brushed over it I'm
shocked to see what next to me this is
the least shocking news ever um I cuz I
remember 2020 when we were in Dallas
starting pbd
there was breaking news I don't it was
right in the middle of Co maybe June of
2020 I want to say and it was like
breaking news Joe rugan's leaving
YouTube going to Spotify $100 million
deal yeah right we're like what the hell
this is what it was shocking turned out
it was actually a $200 million deal yeah
so we didn't even have the numbers right
CU he kind of slow played that but to me
this is the equivalent like in sports
just locking down your star whether it's
momes signing with the Chiefs whether
it's Joe burrow with the Bengals whether
it's Giannis with the Bucks you're
locking down your star there's going to
be some sort of Hometown discount for
loyalty cuz he could go elsewhere and
get more money but to me The Joe Rogan
seems to be a creature of habit he he
keeps his uh Circle very tight he's very
loyal don't forget Daniel e had his back
during everything with Co so I think
that this was inevitable and um good for
I tell you what again sometimes I go I
go into restaurants and such a bad thing
and I say that I'd love to run a
restaurant one day and just treat
customers royally yeah and and and use
data and paying attention and a little
bit of no no nosy in when people are
talking to see how it can make their day
better day shout out to will gader under
reasonable Hospitality just because
curious what is I'd love to one day run
a sports team just to see what it's like
in a like a past life I I would have
loved to have been a agent representing
certain Talent certain people right
managing certain Talent you know being
an agent you know negotiating on on
their behalf uh I I I knew of a deal
that couldn't gone Joe $350 million okay
yeah and by the way here's a part you
got to realize okay why Joe is very
different and very
unique Spotify knows they have a great
deal here Spotify knows they
underpaid and you
know it's it's important for Spotify
know you're getting somebody that's
still very young how old is joob by way
56 56 years old he's 56 years old and if
I'm right that's can probably the whoop
the average aage 25y old's but you know
happy to hear that 56 is still
considered pretty young Joe can beat the
[__] out of all of us in this room at
the same time but but the point with
this is Gorilla but the point with this
is the fact that even though he could
have gotten that kind of money he stays
shows a lot about his character you
don't want to be an athlete that plays
for four different teams like I like for
example let's just use NBA you don't
want to be the guy that let's just say
you get drafted into Cleveland and then
you go to Miami and then maybe you go
back to Cleveland and you go to La not
that
would you don't want to be you don't
want to be a player like that because
you're constantly changing teams you
want to be a guy that comes straight out
of high school goes in place for one
team for 20 years and your name is Kobe
Bryan you want to be the guy that these
guys gave him a great offer Spotify and
he's like listen man you had my back
when they wanted to cancel me because
those videos and audios guess what I'm
going to have your back and you don't
forget those types of people who
remember when you had their back to come
back and do that for you and it's not
just about money you got to salute
respect to them I think Spotify won and
I also think Rogan won because now the
audience will be able to see it not only
on Spotify but also on YouTube don't
know how they're going to structure that
but I think it's a great negotiation
great deal and they weren't solving for
money only they were solving for growth
expansion future partnership and I like
that I think the meeting was probably
and by the way just so everybody knows I
have not spoken to Joe about this deal
not this much zero so it's not like I
know anything about the deal he hasn't
called me about the we haven't talked
about the deal nothing nothing that is
is just about the fact that I know I had
one offer for him but the deal is done
based on Spotify also wanting to wanting
to ask I foresee that in the negotiation
being hey what do you want to do to make
the deal better what's important to you
and I think one of the things Jo
probably wanted to do was to make sure
the growth in YouTube continues because
he's not far off from you know growing
that exponentially he's already there as
a number one guy but I think he can even
and take it to a whole different level
anyways congratulations Spotify
congratulations to uh um to Joe to Joe
as well yes Bill Mah that was an
interesting podcast you guys have a
chance to uh yes I watched it twice tell
me about it you watch it twice tell me
about it not once twice so um you said
guess how guess how much I spoke versus
he spoke before we even saw the yeah the
interview and I was like I don't know
you probably spoke more you're the one
being interviewed he probably spoke 80%
of the time at minimum Fair number or
no a guy tweeted saying Bill spoke 80 I
think the top comment was Bill spoke 87%
of the time 87% yeah when he's doing the
interview so the the the interview has
15,000 comments you said at this point
something like that insane um the I
think the the credit goes to you pbd
what was that keep going okay credit
goes to you for just this this was you
the whole
time the the Gavin knew something thing
was interesting how he says what' he say
Vinnie I love by the way I I did the Tom
I actually wrote so first of all so the
the the the poking when you're like so
you know because Democrats love data
they're data driven data statistics we
love it it it showed me first of all
that interview you exposed how you
exposed him okay without his wrers Pat
without his liberal audience in in the
you know in what's the show Real Time
with Bill Maher he's that are told when
to applaud and when to this is a moment
where you got to find out who he was as
a individual by himself with nobody else
helping him out and here's my thing
anyone that could utter the phrase I
love Gavin Nome with a straight face and
be and be honest with themselves loses
all credibility when it comes to
anything political I don't want to hear
any of that okay and not be his wife
yeah yeah exactly so and he goes cuz
what you said you're a results driven
guy uh why you because he said Democrats
are more data uh detail driven and you
notice how when you were like okay give
me the fact you know okay okay he
there's there's zero answer for why
you're going to vote it's it's the
anything but Trump attitude and then
regarding his abysmal way uh new has run
Cali to the ground this is you know why
he loves him too besides the you know
slick hair which he kind of got my style
uh nothing that's happening in
California really affects Bill Mt think
about it he's filthy rich so he doesn't
doesn't care Tom about the 60% in taxes
or the record high gas prices because he
can afford it it's a cover charge he can
pay yeah think about that time he
doesn't care about the high crime in
calipat because he lives in a safe area
that's probably has Gates and security
with guns he doesn't care that
California's he doesn't have any kids so
he doesn't care that the California
education system is so bad that two out
of three California students fail to
meet the math standards and more than
half didn't meet the uh State's English
standards he doesn't have kids nothing
that affects the average person bothers
him so he's just like yeah that smug
arrogant attitude and you you I think
you nailed it cuz you stayed calm you
stay and facts always win and when
somebody can't give you answers or back
up their claim you made him look
ridiculous and that's why 15,000 people
are still commenting right now because
you couldn't by the way amazing socks
pbd just throwing that out there but
when you say give me an answer why you
love him and he go okay there's no
answer why you're voting for him because
he's not Trump maybe play this clip Rob
just play this clip on the exchange with
uh uh on Nome do you like Nome how do
you feel about Nome had him on my show
Friday I saw that and uh I I first of
all I love him just you just like a guy
or you don't I've known him for a long
time he's done my show for a long time
do do I love everything he does as the
governor in California no I don't I
wouldn't say I'm undertaxed
uh yeah it's there's I have issues with
this state
he's a guy one reason I want him to run
for president well is cuz he's obviously
a winner this guy could [__] do it
it's insane that we have the guy but we
can't run him because we have the ttoe
around Biden the final winner I love it
he would win the election oh so so he
would win the election he's a talented
debater speaker Communicator deflector
and politician and he's a smart guy he's
he's a smart real guy with a pair of
balls do I love everything no you never
know do with the politician but first of
all I think if he ran for president it
would be great because it would force
him to move to the center now you're
running not just in California I mean
this is California it's weirdo world are
you are you a are you a world are you a
results driven guy I love this no I like
to think watch Things Fall Apart un you
wouldn't build a show that you win build
and win at the levels you won you know
for decades if you weren't results
driven right I mean you're you're you're
Bill Mah you know I what about what do
you mean what's the point about result
I'm going with you so results so results
driven guy right what areas has Nome won
in you said he's a winner winner of the
election he could win the election but
based on what though do you want results
like what has he done to California to
say he's a winner what what oh god I
don't know I it's
too he doesn't know he made it rain okay
dude right there by the way now do me a
favor go to Twitter exactly what I just
I I actually wanted to know because
there's no way in the world you've ran a
state and you don't have victories right
that are big victories so I put on
Twitter serious requests could someone
list three things Nome did to improve
the state of California I'm curious and
if you go to the bottom and go through
comment section this thing you know the
worst got I don't know how many comments
right look at that one right there
improve the sales for UL Kagan Looking
Glass improve the rate it relies on
Government funding improve the amount of
money the IRS receives before U-Haul
keep going to the next one keep going to
the next one there's a bunch of
different comments there obviously
that's one with the San with the santis
with fetus which he was showing go up a
little bit on the santis one yeah the
poop maps go a little bit higher Rob
yeah where it says uh human feces
reports are booming in California
anyways so so the point the point here
becomes it's purely data you know it's
purely data on what's going on and I
could nobody could list anything about
what the guy's done datawise you can
like somebody
for for instance imagine if Nome was
your cousin my cousin if he's your
cousin imagine if Nome was somebody went
to high school with maybe somebody who
played football with and maybe he was a
guy that actually blocked for you and
you were a receiver or he was a tight
end and he actually he he protected you
right maybe you have some kind of
affinity to the guy and there's some
kind of loyalty because there's a
relationship right fine I get defending
because you are friends cool but at the
end of the day data is data 100% okay
there is there is nothing one can say on
why the number one state that's lost the
most customers ever is Nome you know how
he says and this is his famous line he
says well you know California is the the
you know California is the fifth largest
economy in the world and you know
California is the the same as the
equivalent of 21 states combined and
that's what California okay great you
know what he sounds like you know the
Vander builds he was the richest man in
the world okay
you know his kids were the snobbiest
sloppiest you know you want to call him
a a spoiled kids that wasted the money
so you can still be rich but you lost a
lot of your daddy's money Nome is that
billionaire son whose dad used to be
worth $40 billion after he died now the
son is worth $17 billion but he says I'm
still one the richest man in the world
that's 17 yeah but you lost your dad's
23 $3 billion you lost customers that
left your state there is no other way
there has to be a way to judge
somebody's record right there has to be
like in sports how do they judge a big
man I saw a debate between uh uh
somebody on ESPN with Stephen A SM how
do you judge a great Center based on
what but Center it comes to Rings right
how do you judge a great podcaster based
on what views views views and what
eyeballs subscribership eyeballs
influence how do you judge a great
singer you
know and what else
judb you can say whatever you want about
Taylor Swift we can sit and [__] about
the fact that she's gonna you know
endorse Biden which she will and guess
what it's GNA help yes why though
because she's got hits you can hate
Taylor Swift all you want she made5
billion from her music last year because
she's got data and stats and customers
willing to go I couldn't name you one of
her songs not one of her songs could I
name but guess what she has she has
stats right no matter how much we say
even about people you don't like if they
have data you have to be quiet I'm not a
LeBron fan guess what you know what the
data backs up that he's the second
greatest player of all time you have to
give him that that credit he is not my
favorite guy to watch Ever but he's the
second greatest basketball player of all
time why based on what B B on stats
there's nothing debating that so when
you say Nome is a winner and you can't
name stats that's when I'm like I don't
know where this discussion is going to
go I love the I flipped it and I started
interviewing instead of you know being a
guest on the show I love the
vanderbolten talk about uh results
driven approach I'm sure you have a guy
in the organization that's like Dude you
remember Pat in 2019 when I was the
number one guy and I this is what I've
done but where you at in 2024 yeah of
course where you at in 2024 the old what
have you done for me lately approach the
reason that LeBron to use his name again
still has credibility this guy's still
putting up numb no question about that
he's still putting up numbers he got um
nominated or uh vote counting 20th
All-Star game ever broke the record
right y LeBron whether you disagree with
him or not still putting up results the
the Gavin knew something I think why the
Vanderbilt uh metaphor is so appropriate
it's like he's still clinging to the
talking points of how great California
was Slash still is GDP wise but if you
go through those comments how many
people were able to put together a threo
cohesive statement of what Gavin Newsome
was done this is the age-old
conversation we've had personality over
politics said Ronda santus
destroyed Gavin Nome with facts and data
in a debate yet yet Gavin Nome still won
that freaking debate 100% because
politics is entertainment at this point
Y you have to win the crowd as they say
in Gladiator and the crowd ain't looking
is but isn't that doesn't that isn't
that kind of not scary it's kind of dumb
if you ask me like somebody like a bill
Mah that's just like he'd 100% vote for
Gavin with zero stats horrible track
record but you know Adam you know why
because it's not Trump it's that is at
the end of the day they would rather
have somebody that's going to screw them
over but he's not this guy and that's
where the Trump derang you ever seen the
movie original sin oh damn Angelina jul
and got a long time okay so what's the
issue with that movie what is the issue
what is the premise of that movie
Antonio cannot leave her because her
spell has gotten him he lost everything
right she destroyed his life but he is
obsessed yeah with her right sometimes
you can be obsessed with somebody that
can destroy your life because they are
attractive and they're smooth and
they're good Every Man's fallen for this
before every woman has fallen for this
before if you haven't fallen for it
before maybe because the Mark is not
interested odds are you have fallen for
this before who was it that compared
California to their ex-girlfriend was it
Mike mik Mike Mike Malik he's like
that's like that ex-girlfriend that you
just can't get over she's horrible for
you great analogy she's ruining your
life but you just can't
look got that the last word in gav the
mountains the last word in Gavin Newsome
is you got to
remember perception and position or the
is the realm of the politician and
that's all he needs to do he's got the
perception and that is exactly what Bill
Maher was talking about he's a winner
he's a perception of a winner he's
running for president which is dangerous
because you run on perception and
position he's not running for CEO which
is on results and stats if he's running
for CEO Ron Des sis would be leading by
40 points to be president right now but
it's perception and perception which
makes it very dangerous which is why
it's important to be an informed voter
and to understand where you're putting
your vote and what you're doing because
there's consequences ladies and
gentlemen and Gavin Nome has never won a
competitive election in his life you
take a look at the elections that he's
been in and the position that he's taken
becoming mayor of San Francisco and and
and how if if you win the Democrat
primary as the mayor of San Francisco
you you could be the guy pooping on all
the streets and you're still going to
win the election to be mayor let let's
face it if if you've got the little blue
d by your name he has not won a
competitive election because of the way
that the populace in California is
chosen to vote and now the stakes are
high because he could be on a national
stage fantastic and it's dangerous very
insightful what you said perception and
position perception and position
fantastic Insight on that anyways okay
they say perception is reality let's
let's go to the nextory nightmare
tomorrow let's go to the next story Rob
let's go to the Border story okay so
let's go to the Border story on what's
going on over there here we go so a
border deal to cut illegal immigration
is released after months of talks okay
so border deal is what they call it so
if something is called The Border deal
what would you expect the percentage of
the money to be used to protect the
border right 100% right because if you
say it's a border deal well then let's
let's actually make it a border deal
right so Senate leaders have released a
bipartisan Bill aimed at reducing
illegal border crossing while providing
$118 billion in funds to Ukraine isra is
Taiwan and US borders changes the bill
establishes a new Asylum process sets
higher standards for Asylum claims and
limits the number of immigrants claiming
Asylum to prevent system overload I've
seen enough this bill is even worse than
we expected and won't come close to
ending the Border catastrophe said
speaker Mike Johnson President Biden
supports the bill calling the
immigration provision the toughest and
fairest set of Border reforms in decades
the legislation aims to end Catch and
Release with a new process for Rapid
migrant processing and heightened
screening it allows for immediate
deportations for those who don't qualify
for Asylum alongside temporary shutdown
Powers if daily Crossing exceed certain
thresholds here's what I want you to be
thinking about how much money do we just
say $118 billion $18 billion okay out of
the $118 billion I want to ask the
audience okay added $118 billion how how
much of it do you you think is being
used for the Border how much of it do
you think is being used for Ukraine okay
I want you to think about it I hope
that's not being shown yet what what
portion of that money you think is being
used do you know the number Adam or you
so what portion of the 118 do you think
is being used for the Border what
percentage you think is being used for
Ukraine so it's 118 between Ukraine
Israel Taiwan and the US border you want
to know the percentage that is going to
Ukraine maybe give the dollar man you
got $118 billion how much it is going to
the Border because it's called The
Border Bill the Border our border I
would say10 billion to the border and I
would say uh probably 75 billion to
Ukraine we're close the number 20
billion goes to the Border okay 60
billion yeah goes to Ukraine makes sense
14.1 billion for Israeli security
assistance and about 20 billion to the
new border policy it includes 2.4
billion for operations in rsy where
houti Rebel and Yemen have launched
attacks on shipping Vinnie when you see
something like this what are you
thinking about with this bill here dude
you want to talk about baffled the fact
that it first of all it's called the
Senate's $118 billion emergency National
Security bill it's supposed to be for
our national security so by the way half
the money is going to Ukraine 20 for us
I I hope everybody's paying attention 14
billion is going to the security of
assistance to Israel and just to make it
fair $1 billion and humanitarian
assistance for the civilians caught in
the conflict zones of Gaza they have to
give some money for the innocent people
that are getting uh murdered so it would
also ready for this require Homeland
Security to nearly shut down the Border
not definitely but nearly so and and you
mentioned it P it's it happens if the
illegal migrant Crossings increase more
than 5,000 a day in any given week or if
the average daily encounters reach 4,000
people a day in a span of a week so 1.8
million illegals with would be coming in
every year I'm going to say that again
almost 2 million 1.8 million illegals
are going to be coming into the country
what is it now four I think four million
something like that it's going to be
that so and by the way let's just be H
guys and we throw we throw around these
numbers think about this 60 billion
think really let that sink in is going
to Ukraine by half the money gone that's
why I'm happy that the Republicans are
fighting it and PS uh I'm tired of
everybody going like this Patrick
because you hear this a lot well Jo Joe
Biden can't he even said he said give me
the power Joe Biden and his
administration with mayorcas created
this catastrophe and it and it is a
catastrophe and just FYI for everybody
out there under existing laws that we
have right now including the immigration
nationality Act of 1952 the president of
the United States can turn every single
illegal alien away from the border if he
thinks it's necessary to safeguard on
National Security every single one of
them okay and all he has to do is
enforce the law but if Biden did this
the Democrats would lose all the votes
cuz let's not be stupid I know you guys
aren't dumb you know this is all votes
for generations to come and you wouldn't
be able to launder all this money to to
Ukraine that's the number one thing and
think about this Biden refused I want
you guys to pay attention Biden refus to
use his executive order to reverse the
disaster that he used his executive
authority to create p and you Supreme
Court to fight Texas yeah exactly think
think about that like the president of
the United States and the government are
suing a state because they're stopping
the influx of all these votes and it's
it's absolutely nuts and it should piss
off the people I hope everybody's waking
up Tom what are your thoughts on this
I'm going to show by I'm going to show
you guys a couple videos right now here
in a minute G to piss people off and and
FYI before I go to Tom can you do me a
favor Rob do you have the wo story you
were showing and the wsj story I want to
show something the difference here okay
go to the top of the story so the
audience can see the wsj logo okay so
this is
wsj right and this story is about what
the Border deal cut illegal immigration
quickly runs into trouble right now go
to the wapo story and it says what
Senate negotiators release sweeping
border and military aid Bill okay so now
let's do a quick comparison between
these two on wsj okay go to wsj if
they're saying they're spending the
money how quickly do you want to know
how much money it is and how quickly do
you logical people want to know what
percentage of the money is being used
for the board
how quickly do you want to know that in
the first paragraph second third fourth
fifth sixth or last right in the
beginning okay let's see when wsj shows
it go up a little bit here we go first
paragraph no just a little bit about the
bill second paragraph no about the third
one pretty much at the top it tells you8
billion 60 billion to Ukraine 14.1 to
Israel 20 billion to the border right
and how many paragraphs are there that's
1 2 3 keep going four 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 keep going keep going 14
15 16 17 18 keep going 19 20 21 22 23 24
25 26 27 28 so out of the 28 paragraphs
my God which paragraph is the numbers in
number three three go to wo so you're
going to wo let's do the same exact game
who owns let's see who else Jeff basil
yeah let's see when we're going to know
what percentage look at what it says the
$118 billion do National Security
package is a top priority okay okay
let's go a little lower see how many
paragraphs one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 keep going 15 16 17 18 19 keep
going 20 21 20 uh 21 does 21 out of how
how many go to last 22 23 24 25 26 27 28
29 out of out of 30 paragraphs 21 and I
never saw the number 60 for the amount
see when they say Ukraine by the way
find exactly when they say Ukraine I
because what I saw I thought it was the
last paragraph I want you to find no no
rob you don't need to be up there they
don't show it just go just type in 60
control f60 just type in 60 don't even
put the dollar sign what paragraph is
that $60 billion to Ukraine go all the
way to the bottom four five yeah look at
that one that's coming up like paragraph
18 yeah why hide the number on when it's
going to Ukraine wsa is saying here's
where the numbers are logical people
want to know numbers immediately
emotional people just want to know that
we're fixing the Border no we're not
fixing the Border they should spend that
60 billion protecting the border with
all the stuff that's going on where a
video like this on 60 Minutes where the
lady was Shell Shocked kudos to 60
Minutes for actually showing this
play this clip here Rob they just start
all of these migrants knew about this
particular entry way into California the
answer was in their
hands TI oh you learned on Tik Tok
Chinese people yep Tik Tok is a social
media platform created in China the post
we found had stepbystep instructions for
hiring Smugglers and detailed directions
to that hole we visited wow
struck and routine it all the migrants
walked about a half mile down a dirt
road and waited in line for US border
patrol to arrive by way you how much
surrend you know how much it cost many
of these guys to come here $144,000 each
person some of these guys one of the
guys being interviewed he says yeah I
went to uh I went to uh uh uh Spain and
then I went to Nicaragua and then Costa
Rica and then Colombia and then I went
over here $14,000 to finally come in and
they learned how to do it on Tik Tok so
Tom your thoughts on this you you so
whenever you see a bill and you see the
name of the bill in election year it's
almost like getting juice for your kids
if it says orange juice and you turn
around the back of the bottle and says
contains less than 2% fruit juice ever
seen that yeah let me tell you folks you
should be turning the bottle around on
everything you see on something like
this and you know you're you're the
titles they get put on it you can't
defend you know the the news reporting
here on on the biases on how far it goes
back and forth because they're not
helping you you you got to look into it
and you got to read multiple stories and
figure out what's going on and what this
is this is election year pork because
there's still a group of people in
Congress that want to keep funding
Ukraine there's an there's a a wing of
the National Security Agency and a
prominent mainstream presidential
candidate Nikki Haley I'm looking at you
um who want more for Ukraine once more
for the defense industry and and the
deal cut this is a deal that's why you
call it a border deal Bill what made the
deal everybody made a deal everybody cut
a deal and there's a little for this
little for that little for this you know
you just have to read the back of the
bottle and the back of the bottle here
is that American people just are putting
billions and billions and billions more
on top of our deficits on top of our
debt to do all the things that's here
some of them have Noble purposes but
it's pork man this is just a big barrel
of pork being spread around for
everybody's interest putting a
spin headline on it
and selling it think about and I'll give
you another example this really quick
the Affordable Care Act remember that
Obamacare Affordable Care Act now we
know it was to get critical insurance
for 30 million Americans remember that
number simple Affordable Care Act we
need to do it for 30 million Americans
what we saw later is it was a three-year
moratorium on price increases and then
it was unlimited price increases Adam
you're an independent professional you
probably know people that were
independent professionals that went and
got Healthcare it allowed them to raise
Healthcare price prices 20% a year for
the next 5 years remember that that the
health insurance ended up being more
expensive 5 years after Affordable Care
Act than it was before read the back of
the bottle contains less than 2% real
fruit thoughts on this so you know how
um you know the biggest criticism that
Republicans get is if they're rhinos
right oh he's a rhino he's a rhino what
does that mean what does that mean he's
a republican in name only uh that's the
equivalent of what this border bill is
it's a border bill in name only this is
a foreign aid package um grouped in with
a border Bill and uh it's you know to
Tom's credit turn the turn the back of
the fruit juice around and see what the
ingredients are the the biggest thing I
think I just want to add is this the the
the key players here is Speaker of the
House Mike Johnson did you see what he
said on um Meet the Press over the
weekend he sort of distance himself from
Trump because Trump is playing politics
with this he's basic Trump does does not
want this deal cuz he wants to run on
this I will clean this up I will fix the
Border don't sign this bill it's be good
for his politics um Kristen Welker came
out and flat asked asked uh Mike Johnson
are you basically following Trump's lead
on this he said no I'm the guy I'm the
guy running the house I'm the guy saying
that this is what this is that's so
funny play you want is this what you're
talking about is it worth watching or
not really cuz I've only got 17 likes
I don't know about this video but I'm
telling you he basically said that he's
the guy running the show but what's the
point about Trump but here not the stop
but who Trump running on whatever nobody
should be cool with this bill I don't
give a [__] if you're a rhino Left Right
tall short nobody should co-sign on a
bill that's giving half of it to Ukraine
Trump trump doesn't need to run on
anything who who in the right mind if
you're right you want you want to know
who in their right mind who you want to
know mconnell how about every single
senator that signed off on this yeah
guess what they're they're all corrupt
they're all corrupt and they're allans
and Democrats because guess what the
average American that's out there the
people out there that are busting their
asses barely paying their rent and all
that [__] and paying all this crazy tax
to fund Ukraine to hell with that [__]
the Americans by the way and no wonder
why the majority of Americans aren't
pissed off they can't even find the damn
story they just see 118 million buried
in it but that answer I want to know the
answer Adam what what what does it Ma
why does Trump need this to run and
anything anybody should be against this
he should be against this she should be
against it any I think what he's saying
is he doesn't want it to be fixed so it
can help him get reelected because if
Biden fixes it there's not another
problem to fix I think that's what
you're trying to that's exactly what I'm
saying that's what he so he's saying if
God forbid they fix it so this is this
is this is the the liberal argument the
liberal argument is what he just said
right there which is great because we we
we want to know all the arguments the
argument I've heard and I even had this
conversation with Chris
is look they they have something here
why don't they want to sign it because
they know Trump's going to know that
this is not going to help him if this
gets uh uh uh this gets through but the
reality to the people of that camp let's
play that card hey Dems do you really
want to take that away from Trump do it
I dare you you know how use $ 118
billion use all of it on the border
build the damn wall twice as big put a
military in front of it call the
military protect it shut it down don't
take anybody Asylum coming in here for a
year and then guess what you took it
away from Trump but you will not do it
because you're going to use that money
to give it to who you're going to use
that money to give it to Ukraine you
know that you know you're going to be
doing that you know Ukraine is losing
the war in a major way by the way you
know what Ukraine just did you guys hear
about what Ukraine built about a year
and a half it just got I think it just
got done do you know what Ukraine just
built they built a brand spanking new
funeral that fits 1 and2 million people
why why are you doing that Ukraine a
cemetery why are you building a cemetery
that fits one and a half million people
any reason why you're doing that really
yeah why and that's at the beginning of
the war pretty much if you can validate
this Rob new Cemetery New Cemetery for
how many people 1.5 million new Cemetery
for one and a half bar being built in
Ukraine that's August 20 of 2023 that
ain't for Co so you can't be like well
they're doing it for Co no what are you
doing it for because they're losing the
war and no one's talking about it wow
they're getting their asses handed to
them by this guy in Russia that they
keep selling that they're getting
crushed while they're building misses in
ways that all the other military
industrial complect cannot keep up with
Russia's getting their stuff and they're
ready and they're they're ready for all
the stuff that's going on and NATO's
keep saying hey us keep pump the money
man you guys are awesome we won't do it
but us you guys keep wasting that money
let's make us weaker hey us more more
money can you guys do you guys are so
Noble you are so Noble can we get
zilinsky at the house again to look sad
and you guys in the
back go like this you look so Noble in
your legacy they're going to play this
when they go to the museum one day and
they're going to see you were clapping
like this right behind zalinski you guys
are such awesome Noble human beings yeah
one and a half million people why one
and a half million people what in a
country that's how big for what no so
for me where I'm going with this is
slightly different if liberals truly
want to hurt Trump from winning do it go
ahead and do it I dare you I dare you to
take a 100% of $118 billion put it on
the border shut down the border for a
year and a half no new people coming in
including Asylum protect it from
everybody yes you will increase your
chance of winning by 5% and that's all
you need but I guarantee you you will
not do it so don't don't worry to the
people that are on the other side
they're not going to do it so to the
Liberals that are saying well look they
they don't even want to pass this bill
because it's not a border bill it's a
Ukraine bill that's why take the $60
billion out and see how much it would
change go on and take it out but you
won't do it you know who else won't do
it mcconell won't also do it why won't
he do it because this is about the
establishment not wanting to mess with
something like this they're not going to
want to do that this isn't something
they're interested in doing so you're
right in the fact that Trump's Camp is
concerned about that but if the Liberals
truly want to hurt his chances takes if
if right now
imagine the spokesperson on the left
comes out and says the
following we have made a decision um we
are not sending the bill 60 billion to
Ukraine the Border in US is such a
priority because America First this is
the greatest country in the world and we
have to protect our people and we can no
longer tolerate people beating up cops
we can no longer tolerate things like
this we have to protect our citizens who
are born here that's what we have to do
yes Trump will have a hard time beating
the left if they do that this is how big
of a chance that they'll do it you see
it think that is zero you won't do it
they won't do a standalone bill on
anything right now Mike Johnson is is
proposing a standalone bill on Israel
that's the I think the Democrats and the
Republicans both agree uh on that but
they are far from agreement on the
border and Ukraine and that's what both
sides are basically trying to Hitch
their wagon to to basically say at the
end of the day they get to come to some
sort of compromise the Democrats want to
fund Ukraine Republicans want to fund
the border and they got to figure
something out but isn't that but doesn't
that blow your that blows my mind that
that's the argument and then you have
Mitch McConnell going on on the news
going with this little AKA penguin
looking he said guys if we don't give
Ukraine $60 million billion 60 billion
you know you know what he said he goes
American soldiers will die because this
war is going to expand into Europe and
we're going to lose soldiers so wait a
minute you're saying basically give me
this money or else Americans are going
they're a sham but you nailed it if we
have the that 188 mli do it Democrats
yeah I endorse this message if you do it
do it you will not do it not happen go
ahead and do it go ahead because you
care about America First don't you the
Democrats care about America First
rather not Ukraine Ukraine is second
America's first no if that's the case go
ahead and play ball do it
yes you will hurt him but you're not
going to do it that's why the bill is
not being passed cuz you're playing
politics and you're using more than 50%
of $18 billion for Ukraine come on get
out they're going to call the Border
Bill and by the way for the people that
are like well Patrick aren't you an
immigrant legally we applied for green
card in
84 my mom was worried if I'm going to
serve the military in Iran we lived
there to November till July 15th of ' 89
then went to Germany at a camp we waited
a year and a half then fin finally we
got our green card November 28th 1990
came here legally weird word legally as
a proud American born in Iran made in
America legally is the key word the
biggest difference about immigration is
not that we don't want immigrants coming
here but we want them legally that's
what matters and by the way that is why
Trum is losing support from who the
Latino Community there's a tons of stats
we can go over I don't know if you want
to go into this now
but the base of the Latinos what
percentage in 2020 you think voted Biden
versus Trump it's a double digit lead
okay right now dead even amongst Latinos
because Latinos understand especially
that have been here legally are like
what what is what is happening here yeah
that I came here legally Trump's losing
support with latino no no no no he has
now it's dead even oh yeah yeah oh yeah
where it was double digit increase for
Biden 2020 and and then yeah because
they sold the whole he thinks all
Mexicans are rapist BS crap let's go to
let's go into a little bit about the
economy right now okay let's go to uh uh
which one okay here we go luxury home
values to decline across the globe this
year uh uh report say this is this is
bad news for certain markets folks uh if
you're in Here We Go premium real estate
markets worldwide are expected to face
challenge in 2024 with slown residential
Capital value growth compared to 2023
particularly major cities civiles
predicts that at least a dozen of the 30
Global cities it monitors will
experience a significant slowdown with
high in home values Dro in 6% the low
rates since 2019 down from 2.2% 2023
affected cities include Hong Kong New
York San Francisco factors contributing
to the Slowdown include High interest
rates a shortage of available properties
political property markets instability
and China upheaval in the tech industry
and cautious Office return by workers
despite these challenges positive uh
Capital value growth is still
anticipated in 2023 with cities like
Amsterdam Tokyo Sydney
Dubai driving the global average at the
same time Powell came out and I think he
was also on 60 Minutes Tom you watch the
entire interview on 60 Minutes why why
is Market not happy after what Powell
said on 60 Minutes about not lowering
the interest rate as much as people want
him to yeah we'll talk about pal and
then we have a curious data point
happening in the US on housing so what
pal basically said and if you um I I
think I'm going to do a bisck breakdown
of the pal interview because he went
through steps and I think I'll do that
um maybe within the week so people can
understand exactly what he was saying um
what pal was talking about is he said
hey look there's a couple things going
on uh we're only going to lower interest
rates probably three times here's why
because INF inflation is still sitting
in kind of of a stubborn place and we're
a little worried about it we don't want
it to pop back up that would be bad and
we've done a good job so far getting it
to 3 point you know something percent so
that we're within Striking Distance of
2% but I'm going to we need to keep the
pressure on because we think it's worked
and we think that the economy hasn't
fallen into recession because of he
called it the resilience of the American
Consumer uh I call it the drunken
spending of the American Consumer kind
of kept the you know trillion dollars
credit card debt all the buy now pay
later including delinquencies but all of
that kept the economy humming and so now
he's saying look interest rates are
going to say higher longer and then he
cautioned on something he was right on
pricing he said certain Commodities like
gasoline have come down but there's
certain permanent price increases that
we don't see coming down he mentioned
clothing and suit and food products he
said hey inflation has brought them up
they're not coming back down so the
market was disappointed that the
interest rates aren't going to come back
down so companies can get access to
cheap money and that the housing market
would get triggered into a higher speed
because interest rates for mortgages
would come down so when he's talking on
60 Minutes he's like higher rates for
longer three three breaks this year
maybe we'll get down to 6% at the end of
the year and the market goes no I wanted
my ice cream I wanted six drops wanted
cheaper money for for corporate
expansion and I wanted cheaper money for
mortgages to get the housing market
going that's basically so let me ask you
this question so sometimes as a Fed
chair right he's not pleasing the left
nor the right because Trump comes out
and says he would replace political J
Powell as fed share he wanted to replace
JP as a Fed share accusing him of being
political as predicting that he would
cut interest rates to help the Democrats
this year Trump was fiercely critical of
power while he was president from 201 17
to 2021 and his latest comments point to
Serious friction between a fed and the
White House That Could erupt next year
if he def defeats Joe Biden November I
think he's going to do something to
probably help the Democrats it looks
like it looks to me like he's trying to
lower rates for the sake of maybe
getting people elected I don't know when
asked if he would offer another fouryear
term to pow in 2026 Trump who is the
front runner of the Republican
nomination answered I wouldn't do that
although Trump nominated Powell to
Fitcher in 2018 eventually against the
US Central Bank accusing it of keeping
interest rates too high at the time of
the trade Wars with China and Europe in
a Brazen challenge to us central banks
Independence when you hear that okay do
you think Powell is playing politics or
do you think Powell is actually doing a
good job when you look at the last
statement that Powell made I think he's
doing a good job uh you look at the last
state statement that Jay Powell made in
the 60 Minutes interview he said you
know we've done this with integrity and
we're not going to give it up now now it
was something like that it was the very
last thing he said about integrity and
it was a statement he made at the end
I'm summarizing it there I'm not quoting
him but I'm hoping we can find that um
and I think he's
correct chairman of the FED is not a
political position but it can be
politically inconvenient when they do
things for the economy because the other
side can claim victory or it can be
painful and that I think is exactly what
Trump is talking about Trump's referring
to it as political but I I I really
don't think it's that political because
I would I would if he was cow to
Treasury and Janet Yellen and just
dropping rate six seven times then I
would say what the hell is he doing why
is he dropping it as fast as he raised
it we don't need to go back to rates
that are that Rob is this the one Rob
can you play it please there are people
watching this interview who are
skeptical about
that you know I would just say this uh
Integrity is
priceless and at the end that's all you
have and we we we plan on keeping
ours do you believe him I do believe him
and I think three Cuts this year which
keeps dollar value higher remember this
makes the dollar stronger on a trade
basis I think that this is the right
call and um by the way interestingly
enough did you see I I don't think I saw
anything from Jamie diam running to a
microphone saying oh my gosh I'm
bleeding this is terrible we need more
rate Cuts I didn't see that jie Jamie
Diamond is the rational player look I
think jome Paul Drome pel has done a
great job I would give him a very high
grade um people don't understand America
has had the best recovery since Co out
of any major country in the world any
country in the world period name another
country that has done better since the
United States so just and I don't
understand why Biden is not taking
credit for this cuz largely a lot of
part of it is Jerome pal inflation it
was double digits three years ago
currently
3.4%
unemployment skyrocketed during covid
obviously 3.7% those are the two things
that Drome pal is tasked to do so he is
the probably the
most notame recognizable
impactful person in the country and I've
said his name multiple times on the
podcast we all have he's that dude and
he never gets entangled in the political
incorrectness Trump nominated him now
Trump is calling for his head the guy's
doing a good job this is kind of what
like makes me not understand why Trump
by the way what I tell you I actually
like this that no one likes him the the
less the left and the right like a
federal
Reserve chair guy the better for the
economy okay the better neither side
likes him the left guess what the left
wants him to do decrease the rates more
guess what the r wants him to do keep
the rates higher more guess what he's
doing not what either party want exactly
and you know what good for you he he
he's actually playing the independent
role now if he lowers the rates five
times Trump is right if he lowers the
rates only two times the left is right
if he does it three times he's staying
independent but he's given I agree with
you Pat there he's given no indication
that he's playing politics he's given no
indication that he's picking sides he's
completely independent and you have to
give him a good grade I would give him
an a I don't know if I give him an a I
do give him a B+ and the only reason I
give him a B+ uh Adam is because uh I
don't think
we're look I mean just for example do
you want the da to go to 45 5,000 lower
the rate six times this year do you
wanted to go to 50,000 lower the rate
seven times this year I'm being honest
with you if he lowers the rate s times
this year you know where Dow goes to it
touches 45 50,000 this year this year
yeah S&P will go past all these
record-breaking numbers but that doesn't
mean it's good for the economy he can do
that to finish his record as a you know
the record break and then the next guy's
going to come guess what he has to do he
has to increase rates and then the Dow
is going to drop again so the only thing
is I say keep the temperature at this as
long as we keep rates at 6% where people
have to kind and by the way again that
hurts me because I'm in a high value
thing but if it keeps the rates higher
for I think we need to keep and my worry
yeah what's your worry P if if Trump
gets elected he's gonna replace him with
somebody else and they're going to lower
the rates extremely low as a guy in the
real estate business speculation and if
he does that the economy is going to
Skyrocket but then again we'll have the
same thing happening of a lot of fake
success problematic we need to keep it
at around a 6% rate that's a concern of
mine this is not a political position I
finance position I got the person that's
in the in the cabinet is the Secretary
of Treasury Yellen and she is at odds
with power right now and they are trying
to push him for more rate Cuts I'm going
to do a case study on it in about a week
and I'm going to break it down so
everybody can see the difference between
the political player yelling and Powell
which is exactly as you say p trying to
stay in the middle yeah so anyways we'll
see what's going to happen with that
part let's go to New York so New York
City hand out ready so after the guys
flip off beat up the cops what do these
guys do instead New York decides to hand
out $53 million on prepaid credit cards
to migrant families can you imagine that
like imagine your kids do something and
you want to discipline them what did you
do you did that you stole money from
such and such shame on you here's
$11,000 what are you talking about
you're doing this this is not the way
this is exactly that's prompting more of
that same behavior of the spoiled child
that keeps getting arrested and that
keeps bailing him out so let's go
through this folks New York City is
launching $53 million pilot program
providing pre prepaid credit cards to
500 to only 500 migrant families and
hotels replacing the current Food
Service aiming to save the city more oh
my they're making 500 families
millionaires cting more than $7.2
million annually says spokesperson for
mayor Adam is the prepaid cards are can
only be used as specific food related
businesses and migrants must sign an
affidavit agreeing to spend the fund
solely on food and baby supplies they
must sign an affidavit okay got it yeah
yeah for sure I promise I I'll be in
court so a person that can't be sued
with no legal standing in the United
States promise promise sign I've already
broken the law seven times oh I'm not
going to do it an eight time no way not
me speak
the amount allocated depends on family
size and income with a family of four
potentially receiving nearly $1,000 a
month for food if successful the program
could expand to all 15,000 oh my God
15,000 migrant families and hotels since
2022 over 150,000 migrants have arrived
in New York City leading to humanitarian
crisis and significant cost for the city
with mayor Adams traveling to Latin
America to discourage further
immigration read the again where's the
mayor yeah in Latin America to
discourage immigration 50 cents blast
him you know with the plan of giving
prepaid credit cards maybe Trump is the
answer says 50 Cent after the $53
million says WTF mayor Adams call my
phone I don't understand how this works
somebody explained the rapper wrote
after sharing a screen grab of the post
coverage can this can can't explain this
I'm uh stuck maybe Trump is the answer
again he's talking about the whole uh
$53 million can you play the Eric out
I'll find a clip and I'll send it to
it's Eric Adams talking about 50 cents
but go ahead Vinnie dude what what what
dude as a I was born in yers New York
what what the hell is happening to New
York it's Gotham City like what a spit
in the face to the homeless people New
York and I don't mean the ones that are
just young and like on drugs and they're
just begging for money what about the
ones that are just out there they can't
afford it they're they're they're dying
in the streets the veterans and
everybody it's dude this place has
become a it's a joke it's Absolut
abolutely laughable and I feel like
we're living in like that movie
Idiocracy it's absolutely nuts that this
is going on it's like bro why be an
American citizen being illegal is the
way to be and like this is the clip
right here right Pat this is it yeah go
ahead and play this clip and so I know
under first brush you look at and say oh
wait minut what are you doing you
getting people cars but once you dig
into the numbers and in the line You'll
see that this was a smart policy shift
that we're doing on a pilot project with
500 people if this is successful we're
going to expand it even more so that we
can bring down we got to bring down the
course 20% we want to bring down of
course and uh their team are doing their
job so uh I told um 50 Cent to hit me up
I would love to explain it uh to him so
that he can go out and do another tweet
of saying you know what Eric is just a
smart manager and now we understand why
he was elected by the people of the city
of New York to be the mayor he may even
write a song about me
okay just to give you guys a heads up
it's my cousin hit me up about the
pandemonium that's happening in New York
just real quick this money that he wants
to give to these people these illegals
you know what besides beating the hell
out of New York City's finest and
flipping off America I talked about that
last week look at what they're robbing
this lady to grab her phone there's a
gang of like 60 of them okay they're
it's like a moped gang they're they're
they're going around New York P grabbing
this lady and they're D well by the way
this is one of the migrant facilities
inside uh New York can you play this one
look at the [__] show they're trying to
arrest somebody look don't touch me
don't touch
me
No don't touch
me look at this trying to arest look
look look look at
this look look at that's New York that
looks like a third world
country it is it's insane
they grab somebody they arrest him he's
on the ground I'm shocked they did that
I'm shocked they didn't beat the sh the
cops
[Applause]
and she's she's handcuffed too all Rob
stop this and can you show the moped so
apparently there's a moped gang now of
illegals led by one guy that are going
around and robbing people on mopeds like
they do like uh uh I I I saw a couple of
these videos like in Mexico and
Venezuela look at this Rob I sent it to
you on slack uh yeah this is the video
so P this lady's walking with her phone
and then look they grab her and look
they Drager bow what that's in New York
that's in New York they're grabbing
people's cell phones and look this poor
lady bow she probably broke her legs
it's absolutely P it's Gotham City and
my question and I've asked this last
week Pat where are the New Yorkers and I
hate when people like well what are we
supposed to do get in the streets
protest do something nothing is changing
you're going to be overrun soon by the
there's how many hundreds of thousands
there they're robbing you they're
[__] in front of your this point
it's not where are New Yorkers is where
is Batman I mean this is what they're
doing to Gotham City is heartbreaking
and where is May Adams May Adams is in
Latin America to discourage further
migration I have $53 million in cards
you can walk right across in Southwest
will give you a free ticket don't do it
yeah what is he saying exactly and by
the way here's 50 c responding he says I
talked to Eric Adams he broke down why
the pilot program was put in place he
appeared to be on point on top of things
now I want to talk to the governor hok
about the laws preventing him from doing
things to make the situation better in
New York and where the proposed $2.4
billion she's planning on spending on
migrants is coming from not my taxes so
again so it seems like hok and Adams are
going at it but uh I don't think either
one of them neither one of them are
doing a good job for the City of New
York right now Happ that nobody is
listening to kamla remember when kamla
was like don't come yeah don't come
right and then Trump was like I'm going
to come yeah
nobody is listening to this but here's
here's a final point for the economics
of the United States folks a state can't
run a deficit at the end of the year
they have to figure out bonds or they
get relief from the federal government
so when New York does this and New York
is then going to blame the federal
government they will blame the federal
government for all the immigrants that
came to Texas then they'll blame the
Texas uh uh governor for putting them on
buses to New York and then the federal
government will get money sent to New
York which will Gap with their spending
so basically ladies and gentlemen you
and me and our tax dollars are paying
for what Eric Adams is doing because
there will be no deficit in New York
because uh new city because Albany will
cover and then the United States federal
government will cover Albany that's the
way it works this is coming back to you
and me this is not a New York problem
this is increasing the deficit of the
United States of America and the
taxpayers you and me yeah there you go
okay so anybody want to move to New York
Vinnie I mean you mean go back no I'm
good Florida hey you're already funding
it man where's your vote where's your
vote okay next story let's go to Joy
Reed hot Mike you know she was on The
View as a Christian woman you know
giving her position on why you know it's
not her fault the fact that she had a
hot mic you know it's really Governor
Abbott's fault and very Noble of her to
identify who the real person of uh is is
at fault for her saying what she said
about war but by the way for some of the
people that haven't seen it Rob can you
pull up what she actually says and just
pull up the last 5 Seconds cuz I don't
think this shows it so we can see on the
hot mic if you haven't seen it if you
watch the podcast you've obviously seen
it but if you don't watch the podcast
this is what happens first so she's
doing this and she goes to she cuts to a
story and watch what she says real
quietly Biden said he's ready to take
action if Congress is serious about
solving the Border
issue if that bill were the law today
I'd shut down the border right now and
fix it quickly and Congress needs to get
it done starting another [__] War
she's a Christian and then she comes
back okay so now she's obviously caught
and she's on The View they're going to
help her out go ahead this but last week
you had a hot mic moment that got some
attention let's just say he used some
colorful language who doesn't not me I'm
a CHR
but but it seems like you were
criticizing President Biden for starting
another War I don't think you're alone
in concerns of that but is that true
like what was behind this well I'm going
to hit that with a cute no comment no
but what what I'm going to say is I am a
person that I I'm a study war no more
kind of Christian I'm a red letter
Christian I don't believe in war whether
it is the governor of Texas literally
trying to start another civil war over
an issue that his party could solve
Tomorrow there's literally a bill that
they just could pass bill for
UE or whether middle was against theq
War I
was so you know I don't want to say that
there's any sign that is specifically to
blame here but I think the idea I think
for most Americans we're War weary I
think we're all weary of confli that's
why we keep giving money to Ukraine to
continue the war you're right we are War
you can pause it already right there you
s to sound like Trump like the hair is
really I think sink like she's playing
the part yeah she's definitely how about
I don't care about her hair I care about
her hypocrisy I think I'm hoping hair is
a little if she was a real Christian
underneath all this I think you'd see a
little humility and a little things
coming out I I I judge her by her
actions and I'm looking at it and I see
just a hypocrite who is sitting in a job
and and doing what the producer in her
ear is saying to do and and and when the
hot mic was there that was her heart
coming out that's what she why why but
why be upset Tom if if she likes Trump's
hair why does that upset you yeah why is
it why is that not why is it something
that gets you to be bitter about it
there's so other things in life to be
bitter about you're upset with the fact
that she likes Trump's hair yeah leave
it alone I mean you know this is America
I mean we were at the I'm actually
trying just to get to the heart of the
person and say let's evaluate the person
and just close my eyes how do you get to
the heart of the person when you don't
look at the top of their head time you
got to start somewhere and that's that's
the Trump attitude of no war blah blah
blah she sounds like Trump but when
she's not in front of the MSNBC camera
she's America's racist everything sucks
bring on the illegals but when the mic's
off she's anti-war and she's just like
us but it's weird that she's basically
sold her soul for money for the paycheck
to lie to everybody I think 100% she's
she's one of these like and we talked
about this how much are you willing cuz
I know Adam we talked about this like if
somebody gave you a $100 million would
you do such such and this I wouldn't be
able to do it because of my soul I can't
look at the American people and go
everybody's racist let's keep giving
money to Ukraine this is this oh it's
not it's not called pedophile it's
called minor attractive person I can't
do it I can't do it and you this is
proof that she's somebody different in
front of the camera but behind closed
doors she sounds like Donald Trump she
sounds like Trump and I'm I'm obviously
we're joking about the hair which is
hilarious by the way I just going to say
it but my my point is like you have sold
your soul you're not this person and by
the way the view probably one of
probably one of my favorite shows that's
out right now nothing to me is better
television than whoopy Goldberg Joy
Bahar and just a bunch of lonely angry
women just [__] on love I wake up in
the the first I watch why don't we why
don't we talk about like some great
things that's going on in in Vermont
Vermont is debating a millionaire tax
billionaires tax millionaires tax
Massachusetts billionair a billion to
its budget and paid for school lunches
with a similar tax six us States
including Massachusetts have implemented
millionaires tax to generate additional
Revenue with Massachusetts adding a
billion dollars to his budget in 2023
Massachusetts imposed a 4% tax on
individuals earning over 1 million with
a half the proceeds allocated to
education and have to Transportation
Vermont is considering a similar tax
aiming to impose a 3% tax on individuals
adjusted gross income exceeding
$500,000 potentially generating an
approximately $100 million annually for
the state's budget President Joe Biden
has advocated for federal versions of
these tax laws including a proposal for
minimum 20 25% tax on households with a
net worth exceeding $100
million although some of his other tax
increased proposals face hurdles and
Republican controlled House of
Representative Tom what are your
thoughts on this Vermont millionaires
tax uh well that's there's two parts of
that story right there the first part is
very real uh Vermont up there the land
of Birkenstock and Ben and& Jerry and
some real uh whack thinking um this is
you're seeing the first chapter of true
American socialism in terms of income
redistribution
whenever taxes are raised people scream
oh they're redistributing income nope
that is redistributing income how much
do you got I have this much that's not
fair I'm going to take an extra scoop
actually it's worse than that it goes
did you pay your taxes what' you earn
this year I earn this much this year and
I've paid my taxes to Vermont and to the
federal government and I passed an audit
great how much do you still have left in
the bank well over this amount okay
we're going to take 4% of it that's
income redistribution that is Robin Hood
that is take from the rich and give to
the poor and when you this is the first
step of structural socialism people this
is the first step and it's on the books
it's not a threat it's actually working
in not working it's implemented in
Vermont and Massachusetts and other
states behind so you know get ready
buckle up you're you're seeing you're
seeing the implementation right here and
it it worries me Adam know earlier you
talked about perception is reality right
and if you ask the average person living
in Massachusetts or Vermont or any of
the states that are possibly going to be
advocating for this millionaire attack
so be like why is it fair that these
guys make over a million dollars a year
have a net worth of hundred million it's
not fair it's not fair it's not fair
they don't look into the slippery slope
of being like the wealth redistribution
they don't go that fur
they don't say well you know that's
actually antithetical to how we operate
here in capitalistic societies and
they're basically endorsing socialism
unbeknownst to them uh and that is
Bernie Sanders country Vermont so uh I
would not be shocked if that passes you
would not be shocked if that passes in
Vermont Vermont Tom do you think there's
any likelihood that eventually that'll
be done in the states like Federal at
the highest level where there'll be a
Millionaire's tax you think that'll
happen in our lifetime yeah I think it
will and I and federal not state federal
federal yeah Federal I think it will
because
2024 I'll tell you when it'll happen if
the
election
2024 I I think it will happen at the
federal level in um March of
2033 when they uh when the 2032
president is uh inaugurated I think
that's when you're you're finally going
to see it at the federal level I'm I'm
counting the elections here and I'm
counting the years and I think it's I
think it's uh eight years away the
scariest thing to me is this half a
million dollar
3% cuz you know when you throw out
ridiculous numbers tax you know if
you're worth a hundred million most
people aren't just like ah well you know
who knows how many people like that you
know we know $150 million ain't what it
used to be it used to be man we all know
that but we plenty of guys who are
making a half a million dollars a year
and now they're going to take three more
per when you're already basically paying
the progressive tax rates so it's
frustrating for high income earners
because this is um it disincentivizes
well that's the key that's the key if
you if you keep doing that and you keep
going after those guys you know it's
it's your your the incentive to want to
work your ass off to your business and
you're literally a slave to your
business for many many years you don't
have a life for many many years a
difference between maybe a second gen
third gen where you're getting the money
from your family and that's passed down
to you and even that that is the family
worked hard to be able to pass it down
to the to the kids and you know there's
stipulations on how you pass that money
over to them but you have to incentivize
younger people willing to work hard and
make that money and keep that money but
apparently that's not something that's
popular in the state of Vermont I got a
movie I want to show you and a movie of
Alexander that's you know come out I
don't know if you guys have seen it or
not two I got a video I the other day by
someone that I just want to share and
get your thoughts on this and last but
not least we got another video of
McMahon interview of a former employee
this is an older interview for us to
watch then I got two other stories and
then we'll wrap up with M gr go Ahad and
play this Clips I don't know who send
this to me but I didn't want to say what
she said I just wanted to share it
because she makes a very interesting
point and I want to talk about let's go
and play this rap 1% of the population
control the world 4% of the population
are their puppets 90% of this population
is a zombie is a sleeping zombie and 5%
are trying to wake up the zombies did
you get 1% make sure that the 4% stop
the 5% from waking up the 90% do it
again play again is not a war between
two religions this is Play It Again okay
so pause pause it first again we caught
the first one which was what
1% runs the world 4% are their po
puppets 90% are zombies 5% are trying to
fight the 1% from controlling the world
and then she gives a second part play it
again Rob 1% of the population control
the world 4% of the population are their
puppets 90% of this population is a
zombie is a sleeping zombie and 5% are
trying to wake up the zombies the 1%
make sure that the 4% stop the 5% from
waking up the 90% this is not a war
between two religions this is not an
ethnic War this is not a racist War it's
none of these this is the oldest trick
in the book divide and conquer this is
what war does they create the division
they make sure you are racist you're in
uh controlled by fear you're breathing
hate in order to divide so they can
conquer do you know how a magician does
his trick so basically he has a plan and
in order for him to do the trick Without
You noticing he does this loud and thing
here so it distracts you constantly
while this is happening he slowly creeps
up from behind to implement his magic
trick and then magic that's exactly what
the politicians do they are distracting
us with you know we are
not this R religion in order for them
what's her name can we give her can you
see if the name is on who this is see if
just zoom out a little bit to see if
there's a name to it okay there's not a
name okay all good well whoever it is
good for you so again what was the
second part she said Vinnie you kind of
look like you like her you're not even
looking at I mean she's but I mean she
she sounds like someone that I could
definitely have dinner with Vinnie like
sit there like she said too many
percentages all I know is I like herred
with the percentages but basically that
did you hear what she said the 1% is
doing everything they can to not allow
the 5% to wake up the 90% up but it's
true it's very true and and the bril
part not racial it's not religion it's
not any of that div and Conquer don't
wake them up because the 99% we have the
power but they're very very good at
making us all fight on some dumb [__] so
brilant if you're watching this which
one are you a part of think about it the
are you are you part of the one the four
the five the 90 think about the the and
by the way everybody at one point was
part of what camp the 90 Camp of course
everybody was part of the 90 Camp
because so so easy to buy into what
these guys are saying they got the
degrees they got the education they look
good they looked apart you know they
went to XYZ school they should know what
they're doing right they're smarter than
me I should listen to them and all of a
sudden boom wait a minute nah pump the
brakes I'm not willing to do that the
game didn't changes right on where it
goes to what do what do you think our
audience your audience is uh the
percentage of the where the I mean they
have to be the 5% I think these people
out here are they're awake we're not
woke we're aw wake we I think your
audience bat is trying to wake up the
90% I give this audience a a really high
5% factor and I think that 5% has gotten
bigger in the past couple let's say you
know seven seven years that 5% is
getting bigger but I mean don't get me
wrong there's no there is no shortage of
the sleeping zombie sheep but I think
our audience I would say is of that is a
big chunk of that 5% that are to
everybody up part of the 9s waking up
little I agree I agree I agree but I I
love I think our cuz I read the I read
the comments I know some people are like
why is Vinnie so angry I'm passionate
and I'm trying to wake up the 90% and
you can't whisper to that 90 you have to
slap them in the head and yell and
that's why I'm amped up at 9:00 in the
morning on some vaults but I think but I
do think that 90% time you nailed it bro
it's they're slowly starting to be like
huh you know what I mean they're they're
waking up and I and I and I give a
credit to our audience cuz I'm in the
chat and these cats are they're we're
we're awake ladies and well this is the
whole conversation with the red pill
versus the blue pill whether it's in
life whether it's in politics whether
it's dating whether it's intersexual
Dynamics whatever it is do you want to
be asleep at the wheel yeah and not know
anything the blue pill or do you want to
know the difficult reality the truth of
life which is the red pill and obviously
I think our audience is obviously on the
red pill Side of Things No Doubt um but
that's the reality of things is that
once you you know what you talk about
peeling back the the curtain open this
is what's happening over here guys go
back most people are like I don't want
to even see what the hell's going on
back
there no you're nailed at him cuz that
that's the people are like I don't even
don't even touch the current because
when when you hear that saying ignorance
is bliss I don't and and we know those
people like just I don't I can't change
and I think that's the problem ignorance
isn't Bliss ignorance is ignorant it's
okay so you asked the question on what
percentage who watches who's our
audience right it's so interesting Rob I
sent you a clip if you can pull that up
I'm at Dylan's game the other day and
the coach of the opposing team when I'm
walking in he stops me and he says man I
got to tell you I never missed a podcast
and I start talking to him I say but he
tells me something very very interesting
Rob if it came your way or not for you
to pull it up the our audience is a very
interesting there's a lot of audience
our big part of our audience is people
that also disagree with us I I know who
who watch we kind of like not not
necessarily that they hate you they
watch it to find leaks in argument but
they also they're they're secretly
closet people who can reason uhhuh and
they're afraid of their ability to
reason that could get them to be like oh
my I'm agreeing with this hurt I don't
want to agree with this but [__]
right a little bit right on what they're
talking about not because we're always
right and not because we're you know
know exactly what we're talking about
it's just we're reasonable people that
have the ability to see BS on all sides
and the gamesmanship and have realized
that this thing went from being
Republican and Democrat to went to left
versus right to went to vac versus not
taking a v to went Force to freedom to
went to establishment anti-establishment
to eventually look man I'm part of the
Freedom Camp they're part of the force
Camp I'm not good with the force Camp
I'm part of the Freedom Camp this is
what I'm willing to do Rob if the video
is not show is it shown on your end or
no cuz I have it on my phone I just have
to send it to this computer can do that
that'd be great uh uh because this guy
pulled me aside and man I I I just want
to show this thing I don't know why it's
giving me a hard time because maybe I'm
did you post it on Instagram let me see
I haven't posted it yet let me see if
this is going to work and this is what
what game p what is's playing game
soccer game he's playing a soccer game
and he says this anyway it's not pulling
up on mine Rob if it's also not pulling
up on yours are you able to get it or no
okay let's see if he's got it cuz I
don't have it and this is just this is
this is just a a parent he's a he's a CO
coach of the opposing team P me as and I
said you're okay if I record this he
says yeah go for it go and play this
clip see if it oh yeah I saw this video
this is great play it the Latino guy so
I'm pulling up to Dylan soccer game he's
got here and he pulls me aside and Maro
says the following to me mar what did
you just say I'm a Democrat but I watch
all pbds podcast so why do you watch it
as a Democrat cuz I like to see both
Point points of view and I respect all
opinions Mar what do you disagree with
tell me like if there's three areas are
like P I disagree with you in the
following areas what would those do
that's a tough question you got to think
about it what business are you what do
you do I'm a coach I'm going talk by the
way he was he was the head coach of the
other side who pull PS you know what but
I'm still watching the content so again
you can be part of the 90 who wants to
go into the five and you want to be able
to think for yourself and you're
allowing the arguments to go through the
test mhm is this a solid argument or not
it is very hard to go through that but
for the people that do that you're going
to get to the other side and it's going
to be something for you you're going to
say oh I never thought this was going to
be me on this end of the you know
Spectrum but another thing to be
thinking about for the longest time have
you ever seen the movie Alexander de
great the original one with Colin frell
the one that came out okay it it wasn't
good it actually flopped it was it was
like eh it was just something to kill
time and I'm a calling FOH guy I
remember Callin FOH from a movie The
Tiger land or something like the old one
I don't know if you've seen it recruit
too with uh alino he's phenomenal so
this movie was a wasn't wasn't that good
of a movie he's done better movies and I
was hoping for another Alexander to come
out and it did come out on Netflix Rob
can you pull up this picture this is not
a joke good looking guy this just came
came out on Netflix you know how long it
takes for him to make out with another
naked man time out how long do you think
it takes out you're dead serious I
didn't even know where you going how
long do you think before this
documentary series 10 minutes 8 minutes
he's kissing another naked man in in the
Alexander the making of a god
documentary nice you know yes Tommy had
a nice butt anyway get back to no but
the point is like listen I know you're
thinking you you want you want to learn
more about what's going on and they want
to put the uh uh the the they can't help
them they're obsession with the sord
fight between eggplants right it's just
it's like I don't know any other proper
is that is that the most why you guys
you guys are
never heard sword fight with I've heard
sword fight it's the egpl sword fight
never heard of the conjoin it's they're
obsessed with it I don't know what it is
like
P that's what they want was he was he
was he gay in real life was who
Alexander no but this is 2,000 years ago
when the guy when his lover died he held
a three-day funeral and it was like a
monthlong morning yeah anyways I was
hoping to see a you know documentary on
Alexander with my kids but obviously
after seeing what's going on the first8
minutes folks if you got kids this is
not a doc for your kids I just wanted to
put that out there Vince McMahon a lot
of stories have come out with Vince
McMahon right this guy a lot of stories
have come out with Vince McMahon did he
do it did he not do it you know the the
word that I disagree that they're using
with Vince is what human trafficking
human this one before yeah but but the
key word is human trafficking y human
trafficking is one thing okay that's not
a uh uh where you're actually
trafficking people making money it's a
business model all of that that you're
doing that Epstein and some people who
are been been accused of in politics
that have been involved in on that
island that the report is going to be
coming out with more names and Whitney
Webb and those types of things well she
wrote a couple books on it this is this
is a bit of a older interview with uh uh
uh with uh Vince McMahon somebody sent
me I think it's worth watching go ahead
play this
Rob there is sexual harassment amongst
the wrestlers or employees the World
Wrestling Federation today there is a
possibility of that that's why I've have
these independent investigators to come
in inv who are these independent
investigators Fairfax group limited
would you therefore believe that because
of all these allegations coming forward
and more and more cooperating evidence
proving that there's no doubt sexual
harassment is running rampid in the
World Wrestling Federation that you are
definitely going to come public and do
something about it why wouldn't I
because you haven't done anything about
it until it became public because you
thought it was under water I no
knowledge of it I made knowledge of it
to you when I was fired and you just
blew it off and let me go I retain
because you were not very good you were
not a very good announcer you could not
the only reason why you I didn't sleep
with your vice president two weeks later
I'm fired why didn't you say right then
why didn't you say hey look Vince your
your vice president made a pass at me
you never told me that no one had any
knowledge Human Resources had no
knowledge of that Renee Duos was waiting
to hear your story why did you wait 6
months you asked me for
$160,000 today otherwise you were coming
on this program I'm happy you're on this
program ex Mr McMahon do not try to
deflect the truth here first and for you
asking for how much money have you asked
for I have never asked for any amount of
money from you you have tried to buy me
off to shut up so I wouldn't come
forward and tell of these allegations
that's running through the World
Wrestling Federation do you I mean
listen wow so goad what year was that I
don't know what year that is Rob it's an
older video because he definitely
doesn't look like 1992 32 years old was
the vice president a female that was
trying to hit on this guy or was it a
guy no they were you know sword fighting
there have been accusations of
homosexual activities yes with underage
children in the WWF as far back is
the'80s there used to be there were um a
group of boys I believe they were called
The Ring boys who accused C WWE
Executives of having sex with them while
they were underage I mean these
allegations against Vitz McMahon are
nothing new they go back to the 80s
there have been women that claim that he
forced them to give them forced the
woman to give him sexual favors and
limousines he was sued by um by uh Brock
Lesnar's wife after she was fired from
the
WWF um back in I'd like to say the late
'90s early 2000s uh he she was sued she
sued him for sexual harassment as well
and Brock Lesnar and Vince McMahon are
also implicated in these um in these
latest accusations by the way there's
nothing to me all that stuff is you say
all the stuff that you say you know
what's got more credibility with me than
anything else when your kids don't want
to be in business with you okay that's
the biggest thing his kids stepped away
don't want to have anything to do with
them wow that's when it's that's that to
me oh yeah you know uh you can say
whatever you want man you can say all
that stuff you know you know that's why
when Hillary Clinton said what about
Trump your kids right can you pull up if
these this guy's kids don't want to have
anything to do with him and you got to
realize like when I mean nothing they
stepped away is Stephanie mcmah has
resigned from WWE co-chair uh executive
officer and chairwoman of her father
Vince was unanimously reelected as a
company's executive chairman Stephanie
mcmah returned from a leave of absence
July to take over as a co-coo and Vince
retired amitt allegations of sexual
misconduct this is when by the way 2023
this is a year ago yeah last year um it
came out that Vince had paid around $12
million to keep um certain sexual
harassment allegations quiet he stepped
away from the board he then came back to
the company at which point Stephanie
walked away and Stephanie was running
the company with her husband uh Triple H
who used to be a wrestler and is now a
high up in the company wow yeah and so
did the brother also step away so the
the brother also stepped away so both of
them stepped away uh Shane McMahon's
departure from WWE happened as a direct
result of events of Royal R is drop
anary 10 so it's it's common so now
while this is going on who bought who
bought WWE what organization bought WWE
same organization that I think owns UFC
so guess what Rah Emanuel does in the
last two weeks what very interesting
move the TKO group The TKO group you
know who they just brought to be a board
member of WWE who who is who who is the
most beloved guy who's got nope who's
got a crystal clear he's got a clean cut
guy you bring in the rock is officially
a member of the board of directors wow
of the TKO they have to do this it's a
great move yeah and the rock is the
right guy to come in to do something
like this because they need somebody
that's stable they need somebody that's
reliable they need somebody for this
space that's dependable and apparently
there was a major eventus last week for
wrestling with him against the other guy
what's the guy's name uh uh Roman Reigns
Roman Reigns yeah apparently they called
it like one of the biggest events of all
time did you follow it or no yeah it's
so dorky sorry we we know go ahead I
want to hear follow some of this stuff
yes uh they brought uh the rock back as
a surprise on Friday night um and he's
going to now face Roman Reigns at
WrestleMania the uh big thing in the
wrestling Community is that there was a
guy who won the when you win the Royal
Rumble the pay-per-view before
WrestleMania if you win that you get a
shot at the Wrestlemania uh main event
to face whoever the champion is for the
belt this guy won it and then the rock
comes out on Friday night surprises
everybody he hugs the guy that won the
Royal Rumble that guy leaves the ring
and then Roman Reigns versus The Rock is
the big hype for Wrestlemania so they're
making this big push to put the rock up
in the main event so people aren't
focusing so much on what's going on with
the allegations and they're focused on
this look it worked for me by the way
and guys called the Genius of Rama man
oh yeah if you guys are wondering Rob is
100% going to a monster truck race this
weekend 100% yeah by the way Rob loved
you when you uh were part of the
bushwhacker crew Bushwacker Brothers
bushwack Brothers pull those
guys brother licking each other on the
head you were part of related to these
guys then we're not ever talking again
The Bu brother look look at look at Rob
look at Rob and his cousin look at that
these guys
video eating sardines wrestling was
great make wrestling great again here's
what I can tell you about Vince McMahon
all these allegations human trafficking
allegations sexual misconduct
allegations sexual harassment
allegations all allegations but I'm I'm
very comfortable with label him a total
creep we all know some creepy ass dudes
out there you've heard these stories
about what he's doing with the girl with
the dildos the text the text is insane I
couldn't read I was just like okay I'm
good some of the weirdest stuff
ever total creep like all
that's yeah that's just I mean that
that's a regular you know Saturday night
for Tom but for him that's
disgusting Tom it's gonna be okay I love
Tom okay so do we have any other stories
Pat do we want to do we have two stories
left do we want to do do we want to do
Haley do we want to do musk and board do
we want to do dad loser's custody for
refusing TR which one do you want to do
the dad the D that story is just people
got to know CU Pi the other one uh what
were the three you got dad loses custody
musk or
Haley uh let's do dad and finish him
musk okay that's what we're doing our
dad loses custody for refusing to trans
son here we go oh my God uh this is the
PJ media Story New York father Dennis
Hannon has lost C custody of his son
Matthew for opposing transgender medical
treatment for the child who later
expressed a desire to live as a bi as
his biological sex so think about it
originally he wanted to sex change
transgender and eventually he's like no
man I just want to stay what I'm right
now Matthew's mother began taking him to
transgender therapist when he was only F
how old that I was saving this how old 5
years old 5 years old exactly she
belongs on jail that's that's that's
where my point is and the boy was
recommended for puberty blockers before
the age of nine y then what's the this
is in New York New York that's how
Dennis Hannon was unaware of his son's
therapy and transgender identification
as Matthew did not express these
feelings with him the situation came to
light when Dennis received a letter from
Matthew's kindergarten addressed to the
parent or guardian of Ruby Rose Hannan
despite never being diagnosed with
gender dysphoria by medical
professionals Matthew was on the fast
track to receive puberty blockers Dennis
Hannah's effort to terminate Matthew's
counseling and protect him from
potential medical harm resulted in him
losing custody spending over $150,000 in
legal fees damn that's a lot of money
and being ordered to pay attorney fees
for for Matthew's mother wow Vinnie is
that like guys first of all and again
how many times am I going to bash New
York and I I mean I love New York my
entire family is still there daily but
dude what New York is completely lost it
that's some evil [__] and you nailed it
how is the mother not in prison for for
20 years are you kidding me the father
by the way the father lost his
retirement dude
$150,000 and then guess what the the the
son was like no I'm not Ruby I'm going
back to to being a boy like if that
right there isn't telling you that
that's just evil incarnate live in front
of your face and this poor guy's life is
ruined and they're siding with the
mother what do we what are we talking
about like is this real life Tom 5 years
old you first of all is that even legal
in New York it is Tom well apparently it
is legal in New York and there's some
sort of counselor and the school was in
on it or cooperating with it because
because sending the note to the guardian
the parent or guardian of Ruby Rose so
the school was accepting or you know
facilitating or participating in calling
him by this alternative name not his
given name and number one and number two
there's
absolutely the the the shocking thing to
me is that there with the outrageous
thing is that there's no outrage right
there's no outrage on the school oh a
5-year-old wants to do this okay wait a
minute so he wants
you know if you it's just shocking to me
because kids go back and forth all the
time on what toy they like and now
you're going to start giving
him puberty blockers and and chemicals
to make permanent life change at 5 years
old come on come on so you know the
age-old question is is nature versus
nurture clearly this is a nurture
situation right here um but we covered
we didn't this was a story I didn't want
to focus on this particular
specific story I don't know what
happened it's it's it's ridiculous
disgusting what I do want to focus on is
basically what's happening to America so
this is this is an article from The
Daily Mail January 22nd the rates of
gender dysphoria have increased in every
US state except South Dakota from 2018
to 2023 okay with the sharpest Rises
seen in Virginia of all cases so they
basically break down what states this
gender dysphoria has been sort of
rearing it's ugly head more than
anything and what states it's actually
been decreasing or the smallest amounts
um top 10 states Virginia up
274 per. what then you got Indiana 247
Utah 193 Alaska 183 South Carolina
171% Delaware 170 Kansas 147 Washington
State 145 Colorado 145 Maine 135
this isn't a red or blue thing okay
these are states all across the country
in each of these states states with the
smallest increases the least South
Dakota only you because there snow and
nobody's there but then Hawaii only 6%
Connecticut 10% Iowa Florida Alabama
Arkansas Oklahoma Wisconsin and even New
York all on the bottom 10 of state who's
the minus 23 Rob who's the minus 23 that
is South Dakota okay and Florida's at 35
yes so it's up in every single state
across the country except South Dakota
Christy know him right so the lgbtq all
that push all that all that all that t
is the T look at how look at how that
remember we were talking about that
small minority it's working it is
working bro you
193% in Utah that means everybody's
going to be trans that's insane
Banas what I'm saying Mormon this is in
every state across the country red or
blue or purple it's very weird W Rob
who's the 274 is that Virginia the 274
27 they're number one they're leading
the league dude right outside of DC
talking about these policies this is
shocking this is weird gender dysphoria
is skyrocketing in America I would love
to know why it's only 6% in Hawaii I is
it Hawaiian Samoans is it something that
within their culture that's not accepted
like I would love to learn more about
take a look at the top P this is gender
dysphoria
diagnosis so where you've got the
radical School Board I know something
about these stats Adam's correct to pull
this up like this and but you dive into
deeply in these stats and you have a
couple things one you have
year-over-year change like in Indiana
Indiana the year-over-year changed
247 because only recently did they get
on the school boards and they wanted to
start diagnosing it so if it was very
small before Pat you know lost of big
numbers and lost small numbers
that if you had 10 before but now you've
got uh 20 37 oh my gosh we're up 270%
right um and so you've got school boards
now that become woke and say well that's
gender dysphoria that's gender dysphoria
that's gender dysphoria that's gender
dysphoria and so you you you have
radicalized school boards that are
creating guidance counselors where
remember this is not medical diagnosis
this is psychologist and and and psychic
diagnosis which this incredible low
standard it's not like do you have
leukemia or do you not this is arbitrary
very arbitrary and very subjective at
the hands of practitioners who may be
woke and more likely to say oh you're
depressed you don't feel accepted maybe
it's just the real you is trapped in the
wrong body and you say that to a
confused 13-year-old and they're like
maybe I am tell you what I'll go get my
gun and I'll come back and I'll write a
letter about white people I I'll be
right back and you get a shooter yeah
and this is where you see in in in high
schools in gen Z where boys are more
likely to be trending conservative and
girls are more likely to be trending
liberal you see stories pop up where
they're putting tampons in the boys
bathroom we saw that happen in Canada
bless you Pat sneezing on the truth
Pat's allergic to that [__] I think
there was recently another story out
here where they they allergic to that
[__] Connecticut is where it was in
Connecticut within minutes of it being
put up the students tore it down the of
course especially the boys all that
testosterone and then you you have this
stat that we talked about last week
where jenz is more likely to identify as
lgbtq than Republican jeez yeah well
list weird that that stat right there
gives a lot of perspective on what's
going on in America let's do the last
story here before we wrap up with uh
Elon Musk so Elon Musk has had a a rough
week uh to say the least he's being
targeted left and right these guys just
don't want to see this guy do anything
Tesla's board first faces a tornado
situation after musk's $55 billion pay
package was struck down uh analysts say
now uh let's let's break down with this
$55 pay packages uh wedbush Securities a
financial advisory firm released a
report on Friday calling the decision an
absolute shocker it now creates a
tornado situation for Tesla's board
Tesla's board in the next move with the
street closely watch ing this poker move
and potential statement the said the
report added that Tesla had not yet made
an official statement and that the
precise ripple effect uh remained to be
seen ruling found that musk's $55
billion compensation package was beyond
the bound of reasonable judgment the
Court ruled in favor of the plain if a
Tesla sharehold holder who argued that
musk had und unduly influen the pay plan
through his close personal relationship
with board members put simply neither
the compensation committee nor the board
acted in the best interest of the
company when negotiating
musk's Compensation Plan said the judge
McCormick of Delaware Court of chancell
wrote In fact this is barely any
evidence of negotiation okay so that's
being shut down because of a judge then
at the same time look at the timing of
all these things that are taking place
the next day so this story I just read
you is February 3rd look at the story on
February 4th interesting maybe they're
targeting maybe they're not but there's
a lot of coincidence here taking place
so February 4th story with Elon Musk is
Elon Musk goes told to go to rehab with
friends uh uh uh by concerned friends
Elon Musk was asked to go to billionaire
larison Hawaiian island to dry out from
the drugs around the winter of 2022 when
other friends had expressed their worry
reports as the Wall Street Journal
Witnesses revealed that musk use drugs
such as LSD cocaine ecstasy and
psychedelic mus mushrooms often at
exclusive parties where guest signed
ndas and handed their phones as Wall
Street Journal concerns about musk drug
use extended to the potential
consequences for his businesses
including jeopardizing spacex's
government contracts leading to Res
resignations at the top of his companies
and raising doubts about his ability to
manage them effectively according to
Wall Street Journal resources Tom what's
going on here with Elon Musk Tesla and
the board okay two facts fact number one
Does Elon Musk micro do are used
mushrooms yes he even said allegedly
well he said not allegedly he said he
does have I micro doed yeah I've micro
do SE smoke weed it's all good and he
smoked weed on Joe Rogan's podcast okay
let me tell you 70% of silicon valid
Doos you know I know many people there
that that that smoke grass like drinking
water and smoke grass and get high
however you want to put it whatever the
cultural thing is don't let him and and
micro do it's it's not uncommon so okay
Does Elon Musk do that yeah has he been
rested for D DWI no has he had pictures
taken in the VIP of a club so out of his
mind he can't stand uh like uh probably
12% of NBA's point guards just last year
no no that hasn't happened right so look
at what's not happened um did somebody
probably say hey man you're under a lot
of stress you know you know maybe take
it easy a little bit maybe about hang
with Larry just got out to the island
for a minute that is a hell of a long
way from you know go to rehab and if
you're going to go to rehab you're not
going to go to Larry Ellison's Island
they're going to send you to promises in
Malibu and so what is happening here
there's point one point one does he sure
but suit do the rest of them point two
is
he maintaining extending and driving the
one free speech platform that we truly
have in social media during election
year yes do you think that they're using
0.1 to get it. 2 that's exactly what's
happening I'm on record they this is hit
this is pure hit and and by the way so
when you're looking at this this is the
argument Wall Street Journal writes the
story you have to you have to know who
likes him who doesn't like him just just
always be aware of who likes and who
doesn't like so this is if you can get
Rob all of them start off with the first
one here if you can go to the first one
is the one on cumulative return go to
that one first the cumulative return so
this is from Wall Street Journal that's
not the one the other one yeah if you
can go to cumulative return okay so
check this out magnificent 7 right in
2023 magnificent 7 did
75% okay rest of S&P 500 did 12% it's
very important to know this seven
companies right they did 75% rest of S&P
12% we''ve r we've seen this before
however then wsj breaks down of who's
the best performing magnificent 7 so go
to that one next Rob when you go to this
one Tesla's at the bottom it's down 25%
everything else is pretty much up except
for one but the Magnificent 7 lowest
ranking one is Tesla so okay fair enough
go to the next one on the next chart it
shows you what Tesla's done from
beginning of you know November 2023 to
now you know goes up comes down it's
down the numbers are not looking good
from where it was at to where it's at
today and last but not least if you
break down the last chart this is what
they show the fact that Max 7 is bigger
than country weights combined their msci
of all country World index combined
isn't as big as Apple Microsoft Amazon
Nvidia alphabet Tesla meta that means
Japan France China UK combined are not
not as big as those guys so now let's go
through Tesla couple things the the
debate being made with Tesla this isn't
anything new is whenever you're selling
your business to the market if you're a
car company if you're just a automotive
company so type in most valuable uh
Automotive companies in the world okay
most valuable Automotive companies in
America just type in in America it's
fine not even close in America okay so
check this out so go to this right there
okay right there uh uh right click on
that one it's fine go to the world what
year is that Rob just so we can see 20
it's fine go with that one October's lat
four quarter last year yeah so zoom in
look what they have Tesla $81 billion
wow Toyota is$ 244 three times plus than
Toyota then you got byd Chinese largest
ev competing with Tesla then you got
Porsche 86 billion Vinnie Porsche is 10
times less valuable than Tesla okay
Mercedes-Benz is 12 times less valuable
than Tesla so is all Volkswagen
Volkswagen that owns I think uh Audi if
I'm not mistaken and Lambo I I may be
off on who they own okay stanas Ferrari
Honda is the new fancy word for Chrysler
these are Honda is a $55 billion company
Tesla is an $800 billion company so the
market could be react in many different
ways to say hey Elon you told us this is
a techn olog company but is it really or
is it just an automotive company if it's
an automotive company if you type and
Rob the same exact thing go type in the
same exact thing you did just go back
one and you change one word okay type in
not most valuable companies auto
automotive uh companies with the biggest
Topline Revenue okay uh biggest Revenue
okay not most valueable take that out
and just make it Revenue yeah let's see
what comes up purely Revenue
let's see what comes up zoom in now
watch what happens okay number one is
what look at Revenue now zoom in the
revenue for Volkswagen is
335 then it's Toyota 296 Ford 172 where
do you see Tesla keep going down even
keep going down 11th place by the way
their revenue is 95 billion which is how
much less than first place go to first
place less than stellantis brand you
probably not even heard of forth pretty
much of Volkswagen some Hyundai if I
told you Hyundai did more Revenue last
year than Tesla you would Pro the
somebody should go out there asking
question saying who do you think had a
bigger Topline Revenue last year Hyundai
or Tesla out of a 100 people how many
people you think going to say Hyundai 90
oh I'm sorry Honda of course so what's
the point the market is simply wanting
the answer to a question they asked many
years ago is this a car company or is
this a technology company now no one
knows the real answer to the question
okay nobody does except for one person
when Elan is asking for a $55 billion
package what's he saying Tom if I'm
going to be driving value for this
company I need to know that I can make
$55 billion and Elon doesn't ask for
salary Elon is only asking for not not
for the negotiations that I've seen over
the years all he asks for is if I
increase the company's valuation I want
this much money so for example he's
probably asking if I'm able to increase
Tesla's valuation to $2 trillion I want
to get50 $ billion the average
shareholder to should say what to that
yeah of course take it take the $55
billion no problem right so this judg is
getting in the way I fully understand
what the Market's concern is to see if
Tesla is going to become a tech enabled
company or not if Tesla is going to go
become a a battery company that
everybody else is going to use you know
how many people right now around the
world are not asking him to use his
batteries that he's setting up in
America right now they're going through
him that may take another 3 5 10 years
until he owns all of it right until he
owns all of it so for the people that
are with him and are long-term thinkers
they fully understand what Elon is going
through right now for the people that
are concerned those concerned people are
short-term investors that have to go
explain to their clients that guess what
well you know maybe the better thing to
do is you know elon's going through a
lot of things right now with Twitter and
all this other stuff yes there is a
combination of the Twitter people that
they fear that he controls Twitter
there's a combination of those people
that he's tool out on his freedom speech
guy there's a combination of the people
that are waiting for this thing to
become a tech enabled company cuz the
revenues and skyrocketing there's a
combination of the people that are
wondering where's the truck the Cyber
truck that we thought was going to be
XYZ and there's a combination of him
being a math scientist which only a math
scientist could run a company to a
trillion dollar valuation none of those
guys there are alive operating the
company the only person there that's
operating the company that started it
from nothing to pretty much here not
nothing too small to what it is here
it's Elon Musk and on top of that he
runs another company called SpaceX he
runs another company called Twitter he
runs another company called boring
company he runs another I can go on they
just put their first chip in someone's
brain the other day he's got 10 kids wow
so try to figure all that stuff and he's
a celebrity that's going to parties
that's going to Gatherings that's
traveling to all these other places he's
got a pretty busy schedule he's one of
one can I ask you a question P quick
math you're good with math right pretty
good with math I tried to be okay is uh
5% pretty good comp package for like a
CEO like you say Hey you know and
valuation increase and what we do here
we'll give you 5% is that pretty good
absolutely yeah and I happen to know um
um I won't say it out loud but we both
know a prominent CEO that has been
offered as much as three times that
right yes like
15% what's 5% of a trillion 50 billion
wow that's exactly the math I was doing
earlier when I said 55 billion he's
saying I want to increase the valuation
to to $1.9
trillion I have no problem with it but
the judge doesn't understand capitalism
the judge all they understand is his
tweets the judge doesn't understand what
it is to run a company taking up calls
at 3:00 in the morning and waking up at
6:00 to do a conference call on East
Coast you don't know the life of an
operator anyways guys we covered a lot
of different things I think you were
going to say something did you send
something to him to no gang we cover a
lot of topics here today again remember
at the beginning I gave this to the hats
here's what we said anybody that orders
the future looks bride hat right now
we're doing a buy one get free anyway so
if you order any one of these hats
except for this one this is the purple
and gold series except for this one and
some of the signature series we have any
of these that we have the military the
black the white you buy one you'll get
one free on top of that order above $70
shippings on us on Thursday I will pick
two names random names and we'll send
you a free ticket to the Vault
conference at Palm Beach Convention
Center with many we're going to be
making a lot of surprises there with
10,000 other people we'll spend 3 days
together at Palm Beach Convention Center
take care everybody God bless we'll do
it again I think Thursday Rob yes yes
sir take care bye- bye
bye-bye